höre dass wir treffen jetzt ganz langsam
miteinander ein das machen was wir ihnen
die ganze zeit versprochen haben seit 14
uhr seitdem wir ein bisschen die
erwartungshaltung haben dass die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz der
kanzlerin da erreicht sie das podium
sozusagen mit dem ende hier für sie und
den ergebnissen filmen wir sehen doch
hendrik wüst wir sehen noch olaf scholz
und wir sehen michael müller und jetzt
beginnt das in berlin und das zeigen wir
haben in der tat noch einmal beraten
und dies vor der situation dass die lage
in unserem land ernst ist was die krone
pandemie anbelangt und
dass die belastung in den krankenhäusern
auch teilweise an die grenzen gerät wir
sehen das auch an der tatsache dass
patienten verlegt werden und deshalb
haben wir heute von einem akt der
nationalen solidarität gesprochen damit
wir sinkende infektionszahlen bekommen
und unser gesundheitssystem eben nicht
überlasten sondern entlasten in diesem
zusammenhang
ist auch noch einmal die aufgeführt
unserem beschlusspapier was wir ihnen
schon berichtet hatten bezüglich des
krisenstabs und der imf ziele 30
millionen impfungen
angefangen zu rechnen vom 18 november
bis zum jahresende und dafür eben auch
die notwendigen organisatorischen
maßnahmen der im status wird nicht
dauerhaft anerkannt werden können als
doppelt geimpft und damit abgeschlossen
sondern es wird ja auch auf der ebene
der eu diskutiert das noch neun monaten
der die zweite impfung ihrer gültigkeit
verliert das heißt dass boostern das
nachdem das auffrischungsimpfung ist
ganz wichtig um dann als vollständig
games zu gelten aber natürlich werden
die übergangszeiten so sein dass jeder
auch eine chance hat seinen impfstatus
wieder zu erneuern
wir werden bundesweit einen zugang zu
einrichtungen und veranstaltungen der
kultur und freizeitgestaltung
unabhängig von der instanz nur für den
und genesene ermöglichen es kann
ergänzend auch ein test noch einmal
zweig plus genannt gefordert werden die
zweijährigen werden auch auf den
einzelhandel ausgeweitet ausgenommen
sind die geschäfte des täglichen bedarfs
er soll für alle privaten zusammenkünfte
oder kontakte dann eine strikte grenze
geben wenn sich ein nicht geimpfte
personen dabei befindet und zwar geht es
darum dann den eigenen haushalt sowie
höchstens zwei personen eines weiteren
haushalts also überall wo nicht alle
teilnehmer geimpft und genesen sind gilt
diese grenze eigene haushalts die
höchsten zwei weitere personen kinder
bis zur vollendung des 14 jahres sind
hiervon ausgenommen
wir haben uns dann lange mit
überregionalen sport kultur und
vergleichbaren großveranstaltungen
beschäftigt vielleicht können die
ländervertreter dazu dann nachher etwas
sagen
spätestens ab einer inzidenz von mehr
als 350 neuinfektionen in sieben tagen
pro 100000 einwohner werden clubs und
diskotheken in innenräumen geschlossen
und
es ist dann auch so dass wir
sagen dass dies jetzt rechtlich schon
möglich wäre aber es wird noch einmal
gemeinsam vereinbart in kreisen mit
einer inzidenz oberhalb von 350 1 350
fällen pro 100.000 einwohner und sieben
tagen müssen alle kontakte reduziert
werden und deshalb gilt für private
feiern und zusammenkünfte eine
teilnehmer grenze von 50 personen also
geimpfte und genesene in innenräumen und
200 personen geimpfte und genesene im
außenbereich für die wohl ungeimpfte
dabei sind hatte ich ja erst schon die
maßgabe gesagt den schulen die jetzt
eine masken pflicht eine strenge
kontrolle der regeln wird durchgesetzt
und es geht um die weiterentwicklung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes
das ist jetzt ein gesetzgebungsarbeit
die dann bis zum 15 dezember ja auch die
regelungen ersetzen kann oder erweitern
kann die jetzt einen übergangszeitraum
hatten hierzu kann vielleicht auch noch
mal von olaf scholz etwas gesagt werden
weil das ja auch die gesetzgebung der
zukünftigen ampel koalition anbelangt
weist noch mal daraufhin dass alle von
uns genannten maßnahmen quasi
mindeststandards sind das heißt länder
können strenger vorgehen und wir haben
uns noch einmal zur impfpflicht geäußert
eine allgemeine impfpflicht soll im
deutschen bundestag diskutiert und
entschieden werden dazu bitten bund und
länder den ethikrat sich bis jahresende
eine empfehlung zu erarbeiten und dann
kann diese
allgemeine impfpflicht könnte bei
entsprechender entscheidung greifen etwa
ab februar
2022 es wird ein expertengremium von
wissenschaftlern und wissenschaftlern
eingerichtet wir haben uns mit dem
silvester und neujahr
beschäftigt das würde ich auch henrik
überlassen und wir haben uns noch einmal
zu den wirtschaftshilfen verständigt
überbrückungshilfe 4 die natürlich
angesichts der einschränkungen von
großer bedeutung sind sie sehen an den
beschlüssen dass wir verstanden haben
dass die lage sehr ernst ist und dass
wir durch weitergehende maßnahmen
zusätzlich zu den jetzt schon getroffene
maßnahmen im infektionsschutzgesetz noch
einmal dass insbesondere auch in hoch
inzidenz gebieten handeln wollen um
wirklich die arbeit die stündlich und
auch jetzt zu dieser zeit wieder in den
intensivstationen geleistet wird nicht
nur anzuerkennen sondern möglichst auch
weniger notwendig zu machen und dazu
muss die vierte welle gebrochen werden
und das ist bis jetzt noch nicht
geschafft wir haben im augenblick eine
gewisse beruhigung aber auf einem viel
zu hohen niveau und deshalb waren diese
maßnahmen notwendig heute zu beschließen
herr vizekanzler
wir sind in einer sehr sehr schwierigen
situation die alle wissen die hat etwas
damit zu tun dass wir zwar sehr sehr
viele geimpfte bürgern und bürger haben
aber nicht genügend viele
um nicht um sicherstellen zu können dass
nicht erneut sich an der infektionswelle
durch das land gibt das ist die
situation mit der wir konfrontiert sind
und es ist klar was wir als allererstes
erreichen müssen es müssen sich
diejenigen noch durch hinsicht zu lassen
die das bisher nicht gemacht haben und
das ist auch an dieser stelle mein ganz
persönlicher appell dass wir alle
überzeugen den schritt jetzt zu gehen es
ist wirklich wichtig und wir wissen
jetzt endgültig das ist eine konsequenz
hat dass ein großer teil der bürger und
bürger sich bisher nicht durchgerungen
hat sich impfen zu lassen und wenn sich
das jetzt ändern kann dann wäre das sehr
sehr wichtig für mich ist das auch etwas
das mit viel emotionen verbunden ist
denn wir wissen doch was für
lagen auf den intensivstationen
entstehen wie schwierig das ist für die
arbeitskräfte dort für die pflegekräfte
für die ärzte und ärzte mit der lage
umzugehen damit umzugehen dass viele die
sich nicht haben impfen lassen dort
jetzt um ihr leben ringen und deshalb
müssen wir es schaffen dass wir die
situation ändern und das hat noch einmal
der appell sich impfen zu lassen und für
uns alle gilt dass wir das ganz
ehrgeizige vorhaben jetzt in den
vordergrund stellen müssen viele
erstmalig zu impfen und viele die an der
impfung bereits haben mit einem
zusätzlichen schutz impfung zu versehen
dass boostern ist jetzt eine der ganz
ganz großen herausforderung dar um der
krisenstab den general breuer leiten
wird darum aber auch das ehrgeizige ziel
wenn es denn irgendwie erreichbar ist
bis zu 30 millionen impfungen alles
zusammen zu erreichen ist weihnachten
und die kurze zeit danach um zu
erreichen dass dieser schutz auch
tatsächlich eintritt und wir die wellen
brechen können das ist eine große
logistische herausforderung man sieht es
an den fragen und den schwierigkeiten
die überall entstehen wenn es die ärzte
und ärzten impfstoff bestellen wenn
überall neue impfzentren eingerichtet
werden die müssen jetzt laufen das muss
alles ineinandergreifen und genau das
haben wir uns vorgenommen
wir wissen das ist ein ehrgeiziges ziel
ist wenn man die verschiedenen impfungen
zusammenrechnet die da seit unserer
letzten
mpk und seit dem beschluss der stiko
dass alle sich
rust anlassen sollen dass alle eine
auffrischungsimpfung bekommen sollen
seit dieser zeit auf den weg gebracht
haben aber diese kampagne muss jetzt
auch zu ende geführt werden und zwar mit
einem großen ehrgeiz nicht irgendwann
sondern ganz ganz kurzer zeit war das
das wichtigste mittels dass wir haben
und daneben brauchen wir natürlich viele
viele der schon genannten sehr
weitreichenden maßnahmen die dazu
beitragen dass die infektionen sich
nicht ausbreiten können die beschränkung
die wir haben im bereich von gastronomie
und anderen bereichen für zusammenkünfte
2g und 3g die beschränkungen im handel
mit 2g was jetzt neu ist glaube dass das
richtig und notwendig ist dass wir auch
im privaten bereich kontakt beschränkung
festlegen die eben sehr streng sind wenn
ungeimpfte bürgern und bürger dabei sind
notwendigerweise weil das ja eine der
ursachen des infektionsgeschehen es ist
all die anderen dinge sind genannt
worden ich glaube dass es wichtig ist
dass wir klar und präzise sind dass man
sich geeinigt hat und dass das dazu
beitragen kann dass wir jetzt eine
bessere lage gekommen ich bin froh dass
der deutsche bundestag bereits sich auf
den weg gemacht hat darüber zu beraten
eine einrichtungs bezogene in pflicht
einzuführen für einrichtungen in dem
besonders schützenswerte bürgerinnen und
bürger da sind die diesen schutz auch
verdient haben und wofür alles dafür tun
müssen altenpflege einrichtungen und
krankenhäuser und dass wir eine offene
abstimmung im bundestag haben werden
über eine allgemeine impfpflicht der
anschlusses gegeben da glaube ich wird
es jetzt auch vorangehen und aus meiner
sicht sollte ist auch zu anderen solchen
entscheidung des bundestages kommen ich
bin noch ziemlich sicher dass das der
fall sein wird neben dem krisenstab der
das impf und boostern begleitend dafür
sorgt dass alles gut funktioniert wollen
wir uns auch regelmäßig neu beraten
lassen deshalb ein expertenrat von
wissenschaftlern wissenschaftlern dem
eingerichtet wird und er natürlich nicht
nur die bundesregierung und den
bundestag sondern auch die
ministerpräsident und
ministerpräsidenten mit rat und
vorschlägen versehen soll aber es sollen
vorschläge seien die gemeinsam
erarbeitet worden sind die diskutiert
worden sind nicht dass in 15
verschiedenen leben anderer stehen so
etwas muss man sich auseinandersetzen
kann
dass wir alles dafür tun dass diese
situation besser wird das ist das was
hier gemeinsam sich alle vorgenommen
haben und ich bin froh dass in dieser
schwierigen lage der schulterschluss
funktioniert dass die parteipolitik in
den hintergrund tritt die gesundheit der
bürger mitbürger in den vordergrund des
gemeinsamen politischen bestrebens so
soll es die nächste zeit auch weiter
sein es geht um eine große nationale
anstrengung und es geht um solidarität
herr ministerpräsident jüngst bitte ja
vielen sagen im namen der
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten der länder möchte
ich mich an erster stelle war ganz
herzlich bei all denen bedanken die mit
ihrer solidarität helfen dass wir gut
durch die krise kommen und gleichzeitig
alle nicht geimpften dringend aufrufen
die impf angebote wahrzunehmen nicht
erst irgendwann vielleicht im neuen jahr
oder nach weihnachten sondern jetzt sie
retten damit leben unser land ist
weiterhin in einer schwierigen lage es
liegen auch schwierige wochen noch vor
uns die infektionszahlen sind weiterhin
hoch zu hoch ärzte pflegekräfte sind am
limit und arbeiten teilweise schon lange
darüber hinaus und wir haben mit omikron
eine neue gefährliche mutation im land
um das nehmen wir sehr ernst die
ministerpräsidenten von sachsen und
baden württemberg haben heute
eindrücklich die lage dargestellt die in
teilen unseres landes eben nicht nur
kritisch ist sondern dramatisch seit dem
zweiten weltkrieg hatten wir in
deutschland keine vergleichbare
situation im gesundheitswesen wir
brauchen deshalb einen akt der
nationalen solidarität das heißt erstens
wir müssen in den nächsten wochen
konsequent kontakte reduzieren nur so
kann diese vierte welle gebrochen werden
und zweitens impfen impfen ist der weg
raus aus dieser schwierigen lage in der
pandemien deshalb müssen sich alle
impfen lassen die sich impfen lassen
können es ist richtig und es ist wichtig
und es heute auch wirklich gut gewesen
dass wir länder mit dem bund eine
gemeinsame linie abgestimmt haben jetzt
gemeinsam konsequent handeln sie haben
heute ein umfangreiches paket
beschlossen
umfangreiche kontakt beschränkungen für
ungeimpfte deutliche reduktion der
zuschauer war überregionalen
großveranstaltung das gilt auch für
spiegel der fußball bundesliga clubs und
diskotheken werden in vielen
bundesländern geschlossen 2g regeln
werden ausgeweitet die wir an dieser
stelle ausdrücklich betonen dass sind
mindeststandards im übrigen haben wir
auch noch mal das feuerwerksverbot fürs
jahresende aus dem letzten jahr
wiederholt auch das zumindest in den
betroffenen regionen in den besonders
stark betroffenen regionen
gelten selbstverständlich deutlich
strengere regeln gerade in den hotspots
brauchen die verantwortlichen zur
pandemie bekämpfung zusätzliche optionen
das ist auch in den letzten tagen von
vielen kolleginnen und kollegen deutlich
gemacht worden ist der staat gut dass
herr scholz für die künftige regierung
für die mehrheit im deutschen bundestag
erklärt hat dass er bereit ist
nachzubessern das infektionsschutzgesetz
des bundes zu überarbeiten das ist eben
besonders wichtig für die länder mit
besonders hohen infektionszahlen ist die
ziffer 14 in dem beschlusspapier indem
der gesetzgeber gebeten wird das
infektionsschutzgesetz um weitere
regelungen zu ergänzen damit länder und
regionen mit einem besonders hohen
infektionsgeschehen weiterhin
angemessene zusätzliche angebot aber
maßnahmen zum schutz der bevölkerung zur
verfügung haben und darüber hinaus wird
der gesetzgeber gebeten die
übergangsfristen für schutzmaßnahmen im
infektionsschutzgesetz die bis zum 25
november in kraft getreten sind über den
15 dezember hinaus zu verlängern und es
wird gesetzlich klargestellt dass diese
maßnahmen auch regional differenziert
angeordnet werden können das ist ganz
ganz wichtig für regionen mit besonders
hohen infektionszahlen ich bin dankbar
dass das möglich ist liebe frau
bundeskanzlerin zum schluss möchte ich
die gelegenheit nutzen ihnen auch im
namen der ministerpräsident den
ministerpräsidenten herzlich zu danken
die 16 jahre waren gespickt mit vielen
krisen sie haben unser land gut durch
diese teilweise schwierige zeit geführt
in der korona krise stehen sie nach wie
vor dafür den gesundheitsschutz zur
obersten priorität zu machen und
jenseits aller einzelnen fragen hat das
einfach viele menschen leben in
deutschland gerettet deutschland ist in
den bisherigen
gut anderthalb jahren der korona
pandemie besser als andere staaten
durchgekommen ist es ihr verdienst
verehrte frau dr merkel dass sie dabei
auch immer den schulterschluss mit den
ländern gesucht haben wir sind immer
dann besonders stark wenn alle
staatlichen ebenen gemeinsam arbeiten
und zusammen vorankommen wollen und wir
setzen sehr darauf was der nachfolger
hier für kontinuität steht und die
länder auch in zukunft nicht nur dieser
phase als partner sieht will nochmal
einmal zum abschluss dr merkel an ihre
rede vom 18 märz erinnern ich darf sie
zitieren seit der deutschen einheit nein
seit dem zweiten weltkrieg gibt es keine
herausforderung an unser land mehr bei
der es so sehr auf unsere gemeinsame auf
unser gemeinsames solidarisches handeln
ankommt was sie damals gesagt haben gilt
auch heute wir müssen alle solidarität
zeigen deshalb noch einmal der appell
reduzieren sie ihre kontakte lassen sie
sich impfen beziehungsweise boostern und
tragen sie durch vorsicht dazu bei dass
wir diese vierte welle brechen
regierender bürgermeister müller bitter
dieser winter könnte härter werden als
alles andere was wir bisher in der
pandemie erlebt haben ihr könnt der
härter werden wir werden wir nicht
weiter entschlossen eingreifen und
handeln wir haben das in den letzten
monaten bewiesen dass wir das können
dass hier eingreifen gerade auch in den
letzten wochen haben viele länder schon
durch die maßnahmen diese ergriffen
haben auch verhindern können dass diese
fördert situation weiter eskaliert oder
sie haben es sogar schon erreicht dass
es einen leichten rückgang des
infektionsgeschehen es gibt wohl auch
betonen dass auch auf der bundesebene
das passiert ist es wird sehr viel
natürlich darüber gesprochen und
berichtet dass die notlage aufgegeben
wurde durch die entscheidung des
deutschen bundestages aber einhergehen
damit waren weitere massive
möglichkeiten einzugreifen wenn man
alleine
an die 3g regelung am arbeitsplatz denkt
oder auch die entsprechenden home office
regeln sie sind mit beschlossen worden
von der bundesebene und sind weitere
wichtige instrumente im kampf gegen die
pandemie auch für die länder wir haben
heute auch wieder miteinander wichtiger
maßnahmen beschlossen die eben schon
dargestellt wurden und ich glaube dass
es uns damit auch gelingen kann dass
sich die situation auf den
intensivstationen nicht weiter zuspitzt
dass es ja nach wie vor das maß der
dinge denken gesundheitsschutz
sicherzustellen und auch dafür zu sorgen
dass unsere kliniken weiter
leistungsfähig sind und die
schwerstkranken gut versorgen können ich
bin sehr froh dass einige dinge die auch
in den ländern auch bei uns in berlin
schon eine rolle spielen jetzt auch
bundesweit verabredet werden konnten wie
zum beispiel auch die 2g regel am
einzelhandel keine einfache situation
für die einzelhändlerin und
einzelhändler das weiß ich die
reaktionen sind auch entsprechend in
berlin aber wir erleben eben auch die
reaktionen der kunden die sagen sie
finden es richtig und gut dass so
eingegriffen wird und dass es solche
regeln gibt weil sie sich sicherer
fühlen weil sie merken dass er schützt
also insofern konnten wir auch auf diese
erfahrung jetzt gut aufbauen auch andere
dinge einschränkungen bei
veranstaltungen zum beispiel oder
überhaupt das umsetzen der zweig regel
ja praktisch in so gut wie allen
lebensbereichen sind denke ich wichtige
maßnahmen man muss es immer wieder sagen
dass es besonders wichtig ist auch auf
die ungeimpften hier zu reagieren die
ungeimpften machen nun mal den großteil
der infektion und den schweren fälle
auch aus das bedeutet dass eine gruppe
die deutlich in der minderheit wir haben
inzwischen bundesweit eine über 70 die
impfquote also das heißt dass eine
gruppe die deutlich in der minderheit es
eben die ungeimpften für die deutliche
mehrheit der infektionen verantwortlich
ist und darauf muss man reagieren
und ich finde es richtig dass wir
jenseits der frage der speziellen oder
allgemeine impfpflicht jetzt auch
wirklich an einem punkt sind wo das
spürbar ist dass wir darauf reagieren
dass die die die mehrheit darstellen die
vernünftig sind di
verantwortungsbewusst angebote
angenommen haben nämlich die geimpften
dass die möglichkeiten haben die anderen
nicht haben das spiegelt sich auch heute
in unseren verabredungen und in unseren
beschlüssen wieder
letztendlich nicht abschließend aber
auch sagen
alles was wir miteinander beschließen
löst nicht die situation auf dass jeder
auch eigenverantwortlich handeln muss
jeder kann eigenverantwortlich handeln
von institutionen angefangen soll ich an
der stelle auch mal es sind weit
entfernt von einem wirklichen lockdown
wir haben einschränkungen beschlossen
aber wir ermöglichen auch immer noch
länger aber wir ermöglichen dinge wo ein
mindest standard formuliertes und jede
institution für sich auch gruppen kann
kann man nicht noch mehr machen im
übrigen kann auch ein fußball verein mit
seinen fans kontakt aufnehmen und sagen
wir
spielen mit deutlich reduzierter
zuschauerzahl oder vielleicht auch ganz
ohne zuschauer weil uns der
infektionsschutz so wichtig ist dass es
nicht verboten für ein fußball verein so
eine initiative zu ergreifen
genausowenig verboten wie auch für
andere institutionen
und mir begegnet in den letzten tagen
ist auch immer wieder dass menschen auf
mich zukommen und sagen ihr beschließt
da immer weitere einschränkungen wie
wird denn das kontrolliert es wird doch
nicht funktionieren ohne kontrolle muss
zugeben dass ich ein bisschen staunen
über diese diskussionen weil es so gut
wie keinen lebensbereich gibt in dem wir
uns bewegen wo wir uns nicht auf
grundlage von regeln bewegen die wir
gelernt haben von denen wir wissen dass
sie und schützen uns und andere schützen
wir beachten sie ohne dass sie lückenlos
poliert werden wir alle halten an einer
roten ampel und wir wissen das nicht
neben jeder ampel ein polizist steht der
kontrolliert ob wir anhalten aber gern
gelernt dass es uns und andere schützt
dass es sicherer ist an einer roten
ampel zu halten warum ist das eigentlich
nicht so selbstverständlich nach den
letzten anderthalb jahren corona
pandemie möglich also insofern
sage ich ja die politik bleibt in einer
verantwortung rahmenbedingungen zu
setzen das ist unsere aufgabe
und wir kommen dieser aufgabe auch nach
bund wie länder aber es kommt gerade
vielleicht auch für die nächsten monate
noch mal darauf an bis wir eine noch
deutlich höhere impfquote haben auch mit
der durchsetzung der impfpflicht es
kommt für die nächsten monate auch noch
mal auf eigene verantwortung an es gibt
ganz viele die so eigenverantwortlich
schon gehandelt haben in den letzten
monaten
und ich hoffe dass es auch in den
nächsten wochen und monaten immer mehr
tun werden weil sie im wissen wie
wichtig es für unser zusammenleben in
einer solidargemeinschaft ist genau auf
solche regeln die uns und andere
schützen auch zu achten
vielen dank dann kommen wir zu ihren
fragen ich bitte um eine journalistin
gefangen mit dem rinke von reuters
ich habe meine frage an einen scholz und
zwar mit blick darauf dass gerade das 2g
oder die zweige regelung für den handel
bedeutet es gibt ja schon berechnungen
dass das milliarden einbußen
umsatzeinbußen beim handel bedeuten ist
das jetzt eine auch finanzielle
schleifspur für das was die pandemie
bekämpfung bedeutet können sie dann
umfang geben und nachdem er mueller ist
gerade eben erwähnt hatte wie ist das
mit der durchsetzung wie soll in sachsen
wenn in einem landkreis 50 prozent nur
geimpft sind eine solche regel
durchgesetzt werden glauben sie dass das
realistisch ist oder wird das auf
schwierigkeiten stoßen zunächst mal gibt
es ja mehrere länder die bereits zwei
geben haben die eingeführt haben da kann
von der praxis lernen und diese praxis
ist gut das gilt zum beispiel auch hier
in berlin da kann das jeder vor ort sich
anschauen das funktioniert aus meiner
sicht sind wir in einer besonderen
situation
die meisten bürgern und bürger haben
sich impfen lassen das dürfen wir ja
immer nicht beiseite lassen wenn wir
über die gegenwärtige lage reden das ist
anders als vor einem jahr das ist anders
als vor dem letzten winter wo die
impfung ist in aussicht stand nur noch
gar nicht möglich waren als wir zu
diesem zeitpunkt vor einem jahr zusammen
kommen und deshalb ist es jetzt auch
vertretbar zu sagen es gibt diese
zugangsbeschränkung weil ja jeder und
hier die möglichkeit hat durch eine
eigene impfung die lage für sich zu
verändern und genügend impfstoff zur
verfügung steht und jeder das hätte
längst machen können was müssen wir
gleichzeitig im blick haben dass die
wirtschaftlichen folgen abgefedert
werden genau das ist vorgesehen wir
haben sämtliche wirtschaftshilfen alles
das was wir auf den weg gebracht haben
in den letzten jahren dass wir immer
weiter entwickelt haben was wir immer
umfassende ausführliche ausgestaltet
haben
verlängert werden das bulls noch nicht
der fall das abschließend auch noch mal
tun so dass sich alle darauf verlassen
können und das ist glaube ich die gute
grundlage dafür ja und ansonsten gilt
natürlich überall in deutschland impfen
booster das ist der weg aus der krise
herr blank dpa
frau bundeskanzlerin sind sie persönlich
für eine impfpflicht und erlauben sie
eine ganz kurze zweite frage weil es ein
tag des abschieds ist für sie heute die
letzte ministerpräsidenten runde sind
sie erleichtert oder traurig und sehen
sie die krone bekämpfung bei herrn
scholz jetzt in guten händen danke
also ich persönlich glaube nach den
erfahrungen die wir gemacht haben und
wir haben jetzt ja viele viele monate
geworben und dafür uns eingesetzt auf
wahrhaftig allen kanälen dass menschen
sich impfen lassen und müssen trotzdem
sehen dass es eine im flüge gibt die
dazu führt dass die geimpften doch
weiter eingeschränkt sind und dass das
gesundheitssystem an den rand auch der
überlastung
kommt und zum teil regional ja auch
überlastet ist und angesichts dieser
situation
ist es glaube ich wirklich auch geboten
eine solche impfpflicht zu beschließen
das heißt wäre ich im deutschen
bundestag könnte ich sagen dass ich mich
dafür aussprechen würde
also auch dafür stimmen würde und ich
glaube
wir haben alle gehofft dass die
freiwilligkeit hier besser angenommen
wird wir haben auch gehofft dass die
variante delta vielleicht nicht so
aggressiv ist so dass auch eine
immunität der gemeinschaft schon mit
einer geringeren impfquote erreicht
werden könnte nichts spricht dafür dass
wir das jetzt noch schaffen können und
deshalb ist der weg aus der pandemie die
impfung und deshalb muss man dann auch
diesen schuss fällen so jedenfalls meine
überzeugung ansonsten waren
ministerpräsidenten konferenzen immer
teil meiner politischen meines
politischen tageskalenders oder meiner
politischen agenda sie sind oft
herausfordernd gewesen
und das ist auch nicht verwunderlich
denn der föderalismus ist eine große
stärke deutschlands aber er bedeutet
eben auch dass verantwortung auf
verschiedene ebenen verteilt ist und da
gibt es halt auch unterschiedliche
politische überzeugung und dass wir da
immer auch jetzt in dieser großen
herausforderung sowie hendrik wüst sie
benannt hat zu gemeinsamen beschlüssen
gekommen sind das ist gut und das ist
wichtig und ich denke das wird oder
scholz genau so gelingen er hat ja noch
den vorteil dass er aus der länder
perspektive schon mal gearbeitet hat da
durfte ich ihn auch kennenlernen er weiß
also wie ehrgeizig länder sind ihre
sichtweise durchzusetzen
aber der bund hat ja auch seine
interessen und die wird olaf scholz auch
gut vertreten können
trockner deutsche welle
frau bundeskanzlerin haben sie denn das
ziel ihrer kanzlerschaft das ziel dass
sie sich vielleicht selbst gesteckt
haben selbst erreicht und können sie in
dieser pandemie deutschland so an olaf
scholz übergeben wie sie sich das mal
vorgestellt hat in deutschland zu
übergeben also ich muss ganz ehrlich
sagen dass wir jetzt in einer so starken
vierten welle sind das stimmt mich nicht
froh sondern
das bedrückt mich
gerade wenn ich bestimmte regionale
situation sehe und deshalb setze ich
mich und habe ich mich jetzt ja auch bis
zum schluss dafür eingesetzt dass wir
diese vierte welle möglichst schnell
brechen und das hat sich immer wieder
gezeigt dass bundeseinheitliche
maßnahmen hilfreich sind obwohl manches
vielleicht auch regional gemacht werden
könnte und deshalb war mir das jetzt
auch sehr wichtig dass wir am 18
november und jetzt diese
ministerpräsident konferenz noch mal
hatten ich freue mich auch dass was
investiert zu hinter das
infektionsschutzgesetz nicht das
investitions gesetz das
infektionsschutzgesetz noch einmal
überarbeitet wird und ländern auch die
in not sind bei weitere spielräume gibt
also die lage ist leider ernst und ich
wenn wir eine durchschnittliche
incidents jetzt von
130 wie italien hätten oder 150 wäre es
mir wohler das will ich ganz
ausdrücklich sagen und dass wir unser
gesundheitssystem noch einmal so fordern
dass viele menschen auch ihre
operationen auf die sie gehofft haben
die nichts mit krone zu tun haben jetzt
im augenblick nicht bekommen das muss
uns alle anspornen diese vierte welle
schnell zu brechen aber daran wird
gearbeitet und auch wenn ich nicht mehr
da bin für den weiter gearbeitet
herdecker er in dem
herr scholz eine frage an sie
die der der das ziel eine impfpflicht
einzuführen werden sie daran unter allen
umständen festhalten oder ist auch eine
situation denkbar dass sich jetzt doch
unter dem druck der umfassenden zweig
regel so viele menschen impfen lassen
dass sie im januar oder februar dann zu
dem ergebnis kommen dass das nicht nötig
sein wird und ist das möglicherweise
auch ihre hoffnung
ich glaube
dass es richtig ist dass wir jetzt
diesen weg gehen und das ist im
deutschen bundestag darüber diskutiert
weil ja die ursache unserer
gegenwärtigen situation klar bestimmen
sie haben sich nicht gegen bürgerinnen
bürger impfen lassen und alles was wir
jetzt erleben alles was sich gegenwärtig
umtreibt hat etwas damit zu tun
natürlich würden wir jetzt auch wenn bei
einer höheren impfquote alles dafür tun
dass es sich möglichst viele jetzt an
der auffrischungsimpfung holen aber wir
werden nicht diese dringlichkeit wie wir
sie jetzt haben wir könnten das abzielt
zügig aber weniger drastisch angehen als
wir es jetzt machen trotzdem wäre es
natürlich gut wenn wir den effekt hätten
das jetzt schnell die impfquote steigt
aber trotzdem wird es wohl am ende
darauf hinauslaufen müssen dass wir das
dann noch als zielsetzung festhalten
weil das einfach das problem ist dass
wir haben dass es nicht genug sind und
das ist auch der grund warum sich viele
ich eingeschlossen neu
orientiert haben wenn wir eine höhere im
kurse hätten dann würden wir jetzt nicht
darüber diskutieren und insofern ist
ihre frage völlig berechtigt aber wir
haben sie nicht und deshalb müssen wir
das jetzt tun
herr jordan city
ja herr scholz
virologen um ärzte sagen dass bei den
hohen infektionszahlen in den nächsten
wochen täglich hunderte menschen
zusätzlich sterben werden haben sie
schon vor ihrem amtsantritt den ersten
großen fehler gemacht indem sie der
bundeskanzlerin nicht schon vor wochen
die parlamentarische unterstützung für
härtere maßnahmen zugesichert haben
und ergreift gegenseitig sehr sehr
weitreichende maßnahmen viele maßnahmen
gehen weit über das hinaus was wir im
letzten jahr als
handlungsrahmen überhaupt zur verfügung
hatten wir haben jetzt das erste mal 3g
vorschriften in betrieben wir haben drei
geben öffentlichen verkehr das gab es
bisher nicht wir reden über eine
einrichtung bezogene in pflicht und
wären organisieren gegenwärtig eine
allgemeine impfpflicht wir haben sehr
sehr weitreichende einschränkung die
etwas mit zweig zu tun haben also dass
sich zu bestimmten orten nur geimpfte
und genesene bürgerinnen und bürger
begeben können etwas das wir vor sechs
monaten noch nicht machen können weil
nicht genug diesen status haben
erreichen können weil
wurde noch nicht hoch genug war was wir
im letzten jahr hätten überhaupt nicht
machen können weil noch gar nicht der
impfstoff zur verfügung stand als wir
auf dezember zu gehen und deshalb finde
ich es ganz ganz wichtig dass man sich
das immer klar macht es wird im
augenblick mit sehr weitreichenden sehr
drastischen aber präzisen maßnahmen auf
die gegenwärtige lage reagiert maßnahmen
die etwas damit zu tun haben dass wir
eine weitgehend geimpfte aber ein nicht
ausreichend geimpfte bevölkerung haben
das muss immer im hinterkopf sein und
deshalb steht jetzt auch im vordergrund
sehr entschlossenes handeln beim impfen
wir haben deshalb den krisenstab
eingerichtet und wollen jetzt wirklich
die große große aufgabe bewältigen das
sind ganz kurzer zeit ganz viele ihre
auffrischungsimpfung bekommen und sich
viele in diesen verlauf auch noch neue
impfen lassen also es wird hier
entschieden gehandelt und was mir
besonders wichtig ist einvernehmlich
denn das glaube ich haben die
bürgerinnen und bürger auch verdient das
nicht jeden tag irgendjemand sich zu
wort meldet und einen neuen vorschlag
macht sondern dass wir geordnet
miteinander diskutieren da war diese
woche auch sehr gut und wie ich finde
auch beispielgebend wir hatten eine
vertrauliche diskussion der
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten ohne feste
tagesordnung und ohne die
verpflichtungen sofort einen beschluss
zu fassen sind uns aber da so weitgehend
einig geworden dass wir jetzt auch das
alles haben finanzieren können das war
ein guter weg weil es geht ja uns
zusammenführen und ums führen dann kommt
die letzte frage von frau palzer von der
ard
an herrn scholz und vielleicht wenn ich
darf auch nur zum abschied eine kurze
frage danach noch an frau merkel herr
scholz großes thema in deutschland
fußballstadien da gab es ja schon die
situation zum beispiel in sachsen dass
man da so genannte geisterspiele
durchgeführt hat keine zuschauer
zugelassen hat bei ihnen in nordrhein
westfalen waren es dann sehr sehr viele
jetzt hat man sich auf 15.000 geeinigt
es ist aber wieder so ein flickenteppich
für deutschland hätten sie sich da nicht
eine einheit für ganz deutschland
gewünscht dass eben in allen
fußballstadien in ganz deutschland die
gleichen regeln gelten und wirklich nur
die ganz kurze nachfrage an sie frau
bundeskanzlerin
daran warum haben sie sich für dieses
lied du hast den farbfilm vergessen
heute entschieden
sie beschreiben die situation die mich
wie wahrscheinlich fast alle bürgerinnen
und bürger
bewegt hat dass wir einerseits über eine
sehr schwierige lage
reden eine ganz ganz dramatische
situation auf den intensivstationen
unser krankenhäuser das überall
beschränkung festgesetzt werden und auch
zweig für den handel jetzt zum beispiel
ist eine beschränkung die dazu führt
dass es anders läuft als sonst und
gleichzeitig gab es ganz tolle eng
besetzte fußballstadien und deshalb war
es richtig dass alle jetzt hier sich auf
ein gemeinsames vorgehen festlegen und
dann beschränken dass das jetzt hier
entschieden worden und in dem rahmen
gibt es natürlich unterschiedliche
situationen in unterschiedlichen ländern
und einige werden noch weitreichender
beschränkungen ergreifen aber dass man
gesagt hat das kann nicht so bleiben wie
das jetzt ist und da eine sehr
drastische entscheidung getroffen und
das ist gut
ja das lied war ein highlight meiner
jugend die ja bekanntermaßen in der ddr
stattgefunden hat und das lied kam auch
aus der ddr und
zufälligerweise spielte sorgte auch in
einer region die mein früherer wahlkreis
war insofern passt alles zusammen
vielen dank sind schönen nachmittag
[Musik]
es kommt das war das ende der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz angela
merkel die scheidende bundeskanzlerin
ihr mutmaßlicher nachfolger oder scholz
mit den ministerpräsidenten von
nordrhein westfalen hendrik wüst und dem
regierenden bürgermeister von berlin
michael müller der auch noch etwa 20
tage im amt wir wollen dass ein bisschen
noch nach sortieren deswegen danke
erhard scherfer dass sie sich für uns
bereit gehalten haben und auch intensiv
wahrscheinlich den abgleich vorgenommen
haben zwischen der beschlussvorlage und
dem was wir jetzt gehört haben also
sortieren wir mal durch es gab erst mal
grundsätzlich den appell an einen akt
der nationalen solidarität diese
begrifflichkeit tauchte auch bei den
weiteren rednern auf aber die
bundeskanzlerin hatte da den ton gesetzt
also die politik versucht es jetzt
nochmal mit einem verschärften appel und
mit einem ganz deutlichen regelungen ist
das jetzt der neue plan ja das ist der
bekräftigte plan muss man sagen und wenn
sie den akt der nationalen solidarität
ansprechen dann muss man sagen dass hier
regeln beschlossen worden und
verabschiedet worden in dieser runde die
bundesweit gelten und nicht ins events
abhängig sind das heißt auch
bundesländer mit vergleichsweise im
vergleich zum bundesschnitt
niedrigen incidents zahlen auch die
werden diese härteren maßnahmen als sie
bislang vorgenommen haben setzen müssen
beispielsweise zweig im handel die
anderen maßnahmen hatten wir ja schon
vor einiger vor einer guten woche gehört
da war ja konsens darüber über 3g am
arbeitsplatz und 3g im öffentlichen
verkehr wie es olaf scholz gerade auch
noch mal gesagt hat also sowohl im
öffentlichen
personennahverkehr als auch im
fernverkehr diese da gab es ja durchaus
konsens darüber aber jetzt noch mal
viele beschlüsse viele einschränkungen
die bundesweit gelten unabhängig von der
inzidenz wenn die inzidenz steigt
allerdings auch das haben wir gehört von
ab 350 pro 100000 einwohner innerhalb
von einer woche dann sind zusätzliche
maßnahmen nötig oder wie michael müller
der stellvertretende vorsitzende der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz gesagt hat
härtere maßnahmen kann man häufig
ergreifen und hätte man auch in den
vergangenen wochen und monaten schon
ergreifen können also da sind noch
spielräume drin für die länder aber
insgesamt sind sie dann halt doch wieder
erweitert worden im vergleich zu dem was
wir bislang hatten entscheidender aber
ist dieser konsens dieses einverständnis
über die maßnahmen die man jetzt
ergreifen will denn so lassen sie sich
auf jeden fall auch bundesweit sehr viel
besser vermitteln ok also es gibt ein
gemeinsames plateau hinter dem sich auch
alle versammeln die nicht so hohe
instanzen im moment noch haben in
deutschland und das sind wir
angesprochen von herrn müller aber auch
von frau merkel die mindeststandards
über die man noch hinausgehen kann zwei
punkte haben noch einmal aufhorchen
lassen wüst hatte wenn ich es richtig
erinnere erwähnte
zugesagt sei wohl eine weitere änderung
des infektionsschutzgesetzes dass den
ländern noch einmal ein bisschen mehr
spielräume bietet uns zum zweiten wenn
ich nicht falsch verstanden aber er hat
sie korrigieren mich eine mögliche
verlängerung der instrumente für die
länder aus der epidemischen notlage also
auch noch mal ein zugeständnis hier noch
einmal an diese alte debatte die es je
gegeben hat zwischen alter und neuer
regierung die epidemische lage
nationaler tragweite die wird ja jetzt
wohl offensichtlich doch nicht weiter
beschlossen da gab es ja auch heftige
interventionen seitens der fdp
beispielsweise und tat man ja um das
nicht fortschreiben zu müssen auch
andere instrumente vorgeschlagen und vor
allem auch noch mal ein deutlicher
gemacht dass das ganze im
parlamentarischen raum in den ländern
jeweils wenn sie schärfere maßnahmen
haben wollen ja beschließen sollen aber
soll eben parlamentarisch abgesichert
sein im vergleich zu vorher ja die
schließung von gastronomie
beispielsweise incidents gebieten über
350 das ist wie sein sohn punkt der
sicherlich im nächsten oder in der mitte
eine weitere novellierung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes landen wird und
ich muss mal gucken wo landen wird der
beschluss dass das silvesterfeuerwerk
auch in diesem jahr nicht stattfinden
wird der verbot von böllern und raketen
und beziehungsweise der der verbot des
verkaufs händler und hersteller werden
ja ganz offenbar auch entschädigt werden
so war es zu vernehmen aber das stand in
dem uhr stellen geben beschlossen und
meiner ansicht noch nicht drehen
insofern ist das heute im laufe des
tages dann noch aufgenommen haben in
diese liste und dann auch prompt mal
beschlossen wir werden also ein
silvester haben wie im vergangenen aber
bis 30 zwölften geht dann alles wir
werden uns überraschen lassen was
wirklich sozusagen de facto in
deutschland passiert impfpflicht er hat
aber noch wichtiger punkt sind
vorgespräch schon erwähnt oder scholz
das nochmal direkt danach gefragt worden
die kanzlerin sagte werth parlamentarier
würde ich dafür stimmen hält es für
geboten
können sie uns die antwort von olaf
scholz übersetzen einen klaren hauptsatz
habe ich jetzt nicht hören können
deutschland das relativ eindeutig muss
ich sagen dass es sich für diese im
pflicht ausgesprochen hat auch wenn das
natürlich jetzt noch mal
verknüpft hat mit der mit der aktuellen
lage aber offensichtlich geht ja nicht
so wirklich davon aus dass sich in den
kommenden zwei monaten dramatisch
verbessern wir trotz der offensive die
man jetzt anstreben mit 30 millionen
impfungen bis ende des jahres aber es
wird wahrscheinlich weiterhin möglich
werden eine nicht geringe anzahl von
bundesbürgerinnen und bundesbürger davon
zu überzeugen wie wichtig diese impfung
ist und deswegen wird zumindest mal die
allgemeine impfpflicht im politischen
raum als diskussion bestehen bleiben was
tatsächlich an geleistet angeleiert
werden wird ist die impfpflicht für
menschen die in bestimmten einrichtungen
arbeiten also in alten pflegeheimen
krankenhäusern da wird der gesetzentwurf
sicherlich noch in diesem jahr
verabschiedet werden und relativ zügig
dann in kraft treten können das war ja
in den vergangenen tagen immer auch
schon im gespräch dass die allgemeine
impfpflicht nach lage der der impfstoff
des eines vorhandenen impfstoff sache
der infrastruktur deswegen will man ja
unter anderem beispielsweise auch
apothekerin apotheker zahnärztinnen und
zahnärzte und teilweise fach
pflegefachkräfte impfen lassen auch das
muss ja noch mal in einen rechtlichen
rahmen gebracht werden also das sind
aber die hintergründe dafür wenn das
ordentlich anlauf macht sein dass man
noch mal drüber nachdenken kann über die
eben pflicht aber die die möglichkeit
dass eine allgemeine impfpflicht dann ab
ende februar anfang märz in kraft treten
könnte die ist nach wie vor
wahrscheinlich hoch und wahrscheinlich
jetzt sich olaf scholz deswegen in der
formulierung auch ein klein wenig
zurückgehalten vielleicht auf der
tatsächlich noch darauf dass es eine
größere trendwende gibt und die
bereitschaft der bundesbürgerinnen und
bundesbürger zu einer impfung jahren
wächst danke für diese übersetzung er
hat es war die letzte
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz von
angenommen in dieser funktion als
bundeskanzlerin sie hat es selber nicht
mal erwähnt herr wüst hat es dann getan
und prätentiös bis zum schluss ja wie so
wie wir sie kennen auch die auswahl der
titel heute beim großen zapfenstreich
für sie passt ja zu dem was man über
angela merkel weiß wenn man sie jenseits
ihrer rolle als bundeskanzlerin
betrachtet und genau so tritt sie auf
sie wird solche sachen von sich alleine
nie in den vordergrund schieben und das
lob von
hendrik wüst den ministerpräsidenten von
nordrhein westfalen und aktuell
vorsitzenden der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
muss man ja auch mal ein bisschen
genauer unter die lupe nehmen er hat
angela merkel sehr gelobt sie hat
daraufhin gesprochen von einer
herausforderung was die bund länder
runden angeht zum thema corona aber wir
dürfen eben auch nicht vergessen wie
schwer sie daran zu arbeiten und zu
kauen hatte zum teil denn insbesondere
einige ministerpräsidenten nicht zuletzt
aus ihrer eigenen partei haben wäre das
leben ja gerade in diesen runden
definitiv nicht immer leicht gemacht sie
war von anfang an immer für verschärfte
regelungen sie wollte immer einen
schritt weiter gehen und sie durfte es
sind ganz vielen fällen nicht weil eben
tatsächlich auch viele unions
ministerpräsidenten oder seien wir mal
einige zumindest das verhindert haben
und nicht damit einverstanden waren aus
unterschiedlichen gründen während andere
ein anderer unions ministerpräsident
bekanntermaßen ja natürlich immer noch
sehr gerne sehr viel weitergegangen wäre
also das war bestimmt nicht
vergnügungssteuerpflichtig wie man
heutzutage gerne auch schon mal sagt
sondern wirklich anstrengend und auch
als sie einem beschluss eine dieser
runden vor nicht allzu langer zeit um
ostern herum zurücknehmen musste
sicherlich nicht ein höhepunkt ihrer aus
eigener sicht auch höhepunkt ihrer
karriere und zeit als bundeskanzlerin er
hat unser schlusspunkt für dieses
gespräch das timing für die nach merkel
ära wenn es mal so bezeichnen darf nimmt
jetzt offenbar ganz konkrete formen an
wir lesen heute und hören heute dass die
bundestagsverwaltung mehr oder weniger
bestätigt hat dass wir für den kommenden
mittwoch uns schon mal im kalender fest
markieren können achter dezember nicht
nur dieses datum sondern die wahl des
mutmaßlichen nachfolgers also dann ab
dem kommenden mittwoch
da haben wir die bekommen wir die
führung die wir bestellt haben
ja davon können wir glaube ich ausgehen
aber wer selbst wenn es am siebter oder
neunter stattfinden würde werden wir
natürlich vorbereitet auf die wahl des
bundeskanzlers und allem was dazugehört
wird sicherlich ein spannender tag aber
es sind ja noch ein paar termine vorher
wir haben am wochenende zwei kleine
parteitage von spd und fdp die über den
koalitionsvertrag entscheiden dann wird
es noch pressekonferenzen geben zur
ministerin liste aus der spd auch die
grünen müssen ihre ergebnisse online
befragungen noch konto und dann wird der
koalitionsvertrag ja auch noch feierlich
unterzeichnet nachdem er am vergangenen
mittwoch vorgestellt worden ist also in
der tat das wäre ein hochinteressanter
wochen hier auch bei uns und für uns es
wird nicht langweilig ganz herzlichen
dank dass ihr uns das eingeschätzt und
auseinandergesetzt haben er hat scharfe
unser hauptstadtkorrespondenten berlin
dankeschön
meine damen und herren was wir jetzt
vorhaben mit ihnen ist natürlich der
blick noch mal aus der länder
perspektive auf diese corona beschlüsse
der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
wir sammeln verschiedenes ein und
beginnen wir hatten ihn das vorhin schon
mal in einen kleinen zarten mikrofon
gezeigt gegen 14 uhr aber jetzt ist es
konkret geworden tobias hans
ministerpräsident des saarlandes der
auch im kommenden jahr landtagswahlen zu
bestehen hat also auch ganz genau auf
punkt und komma acht meter
die regelmäßigen tests die wir im
saarland ja bereits verpflichtend haben
die sollen tatsächlich bundesweit jetzt
auch gelten denn nur dann sind auch im
übrigen instanzen miteinander
vergleichbar zwischen den bundesländern
war logisch ist da wo in den schulen
getestet wird regelmäßig verfallen mehr
infektionen auf als eben in ländern in
denen das nicht gemacht hat also was wir
heute festgehalten haben als
mindeststandards die sind im
wesentlichen identisch mit dem was wir
im saarland schon haben des weiteren
haben wir heute und das ist ein
wichtiges signal für überregionale
großveranstaltung im bereich von sport
und kultur oder vergleichbarer
großveranstaltungen obergrenzen an
teilnehmerzahlen beschlossen
und zwar ist es so geregelt dass in
geschlossenen räumen maximal 30 bis 50
prozent der auslastung genutzt werden
kann die maximale höchstzahl in
geschlossenen räumen soll 5000 betragen
im freien da gilt ebenfalls diese 30 bis
50 prozent regel auslastung und
gleichzeitig herrscht in all diesen
punkten der veranstaltung natürlich
zweig und die masken pflicht wir haben
das heute noch mal so festgehalten dass
ab einer inzidenz von 350 in den
landkreisen dann auch für private
feierlichkeiten höchstgrenzen gelten für
alle weil wir sagen größere
feierlichkeiten privater natur als 50
personen drin oder 200 personen draußen
das ist jetzt nun wahrlich nicht
angezeigt bei solchen zahlen
außerdem haben wir auch noch mal
gemeinsam festgelegt dass an silvester
das thema
nicht stattfinden soll so wie wir das im
letzten jahr auch schon gemacht haben es
geht da gar nicht darum jemanden die
freude zu nehmen sondern es geht einzig
und allein darum den
pflegekräften den medizinischen kräften
auf unseren intensivstationen zu sagen
bitte macht euch jetzt keine sorgen
wegen silvester dass da noch leute
ankommen die medizinische hilfe bedürfen
wegen bella unfällen das müssen wir
einfach rausnehmen jetzt aus dem system
deswegen haben wir das heute auch schon
frühzeitig festgelegt wir haben außerdem
noch mal gesagt dass die bundesweite
impfkampagne einen schub erhalten soll
das ehrgeizige ziel ist bis weihnachten
30 millionen impfungen durchzuführen
deutschland das thema impfen öffnen für
andere berufsgruppen das heißt der
bundestag will hat der designierte
kanzler scholz zugesagt jetzt schnell
den weg frei machen dafür dass tierärzte
die ärzte zahnärzte
apotheken eben auch mit einbezogen
werden können in die impfkampagne wir
brauchen jetzt wirklich alle um zu
erreichen dass möglichst viele menschen
erst zweit und tritt in form jetzt
erhalten können auch ist über ärztliche
delegation es möglich dass
pflegefachkräfte dann auch impfen können
also wir gehen ganz breitflächig ran
dass diejenigen die in der lage sind
dazu zu impfen dass daneben auch tun
kann wir haben ja im saarland schon den
impf turbo was das boostern das
auffrischen angeht eingeschaltet wir
haben es geschafft innerhalb kürzester
zeit uns vorzubereiten sind jetzt auf
platz zwei aller bundesländer das wird
überall wirklich sehr viel geimpft und
ich will an der stelle mal danke sagen
muss ich jetzt niemand sorgen machen der
zwei impfungen hat und die dritte
impfung jetzt möglicherweise nicht
schnell genug kriegt es wird dafür sorge
getragen dass alle auch zu ersten
impfangebot haben für die tritt impfung
die auffrischungsimpfung bevor der
impfstatus dann weggeht es ist im moment
eu-weit die rede davon dass auf neun
monate zu begrenzen
das zeigt wir haben da im grunde einen
guten puffer und jetzt allen auch das
impfangebot für die auffrischung zu
machen wir haben außerdem mit blick auf
die impfpflicht die im raum steht
beschlossen dass der bund das
einrichtungs bezogen jetzt voranbringt
gesetzgeberisch sehr schnell also mit
blick auf pflegeeinrichtungen und dass
dann der ethik rat befasst wird auch mit
dem thema eine allgemeine
flächendeckende impfpflicht auch das war
mir wichtig dass man hier wirklich den
ethikrat mit einer so wichtigen frage
eben auch befasst bevor dann das
parlament hier eine
gewissensentscheidung der abgeordneten
auch herbeiführen kann ich glaube dass
der richtige umgang mit einem so starken
grundrechtseingriff an dieser stelle wir
haben einmütig begrüßt auch das ist eine
sehr bedeutsame botschaft für alle
gewerbetreibenden im land dass der
vorgelegte termsheet wie das heißt also
wo es um die weiterentwicklung geht der
überbrückungshilfe die jetzt
überbrückungshilfe hier heißt das haben
wir sehr begrüßt dass das jetzt voran
gebracht worden ist wir haben am 18
november 21 ja schon gesagt es braucht
wieder hilfsmaßnahmen zusätzlich zu den
corona schutzmaßnahmen um adventsmärkte
etwa abzudecken um dafür zu sorgen dass
der einzelhandel messen ausstellungen
aber auch die gastronomie hier eben
hilfen bekommt genauso wie kulturvereins
haltung insofern ist da einiges jetzt
noch mal auf den weg gebracht worden im
paket auch für den profisport im übrigen
aber auch entsprechende sonderprogramm
der kfw die es gegeben hat wird
verlängert und auch das kurzarbeitergeld
wird bis zum 31 märz 2022 jetzt schon
verlängert zeigt bund und länder
arbeiten hier an einem strang um
sicherheit vor allem für betroffene
existenzen zu schaffen damit sie jetzt
nicht durch diese erneute krise stärker
noch in schwierigkeiten kommen als sie
ohnehin schon sind will abschließend
sagen dass es aus meiner sicht wichtig
war dass wir heute zusammengekommen sind
mit den ministerpräsidenten
ministerpräsidenten der bundesregierung
amtierend wie kommend und das ist der
beweis dafür dass das instrument der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz ein
wichtiges bleibt und auch in einer phase
des übergangs in der bundesregierung so
mit dafür gesorgt ist dass es stabilität
in deutschland gibt und dass wir die
krise dass wir der krise begegnen können
mit konsequenten maßnahmen unser
föderales system funktioniert das hat
man heute gezeigt jenseits aller
politischen farbenlehre und ich bin
sicher dass wir das auch mit der neuen
bundesregierung ab der nächsten woche
dann so fortsetzen können dankeschön
dankeschön das war noch trennen sein
tobias hans war dass ministerpräsident
des saarlandes cdu natürlich durch die
grenzlage auch immer in einer besonderen
situation aber mit dem boostern doch gut
in die kurve gekommen
ebenfalls gut geht es in mecklenburg
vorpommern sie sehen die vorschau auch
da schaut man intensiv hin gerade
wiedergewählt die ministerpräsidentin
manuela schwesig auch für gleich ein
statement angekündigt das wollen wir
ihnen zeigen bereits eingefangen haben
wir die nachricht und die einschätzung
nach dieser mpk durch den ersten
versammlung den ersten und regierende
bürgermeister der freien und hansestadt
hamburg ein mediziner und spd-politiker
peter tschentscher das zeigen wir jetzt
direkt
herr bürgermeister wurden heute in der
runde auch wurde über einen mechanismus
gesprochen sollten sich die wirksamen
die massnahmen sich als wirksam erweisen
um die vierte welle zu brechen
wir haben das was wir heute beschlossen
haben ja so angelegt dass sollte die
inzidenz sich weiterhin problematisch
entwickeln schrittweise eben diese
verschärften maßnahmen auch bundesweit
eingeführt werden wir sind im norden ja
noch entfernt von diesen grenzen von
einer inzidenz von 350 auch in einigen
bundesländern wird berichtet dass jetzt
mit der inkraftsetzung der 3g regelungen
am arbeitsplatz und in den öffentlichen
nahverkehr dass zumindest der anstieg
der infektionszahlen gestoppt ist wir
müssen uns aber bewusst sein dass die
effekte im gesundheitswesen noch zwei
drei wochen nach laufen so dass wir
eigentlich den gipfel sozusagen der
intensivstation belastung noch gar nicht
erreicht haben und deswegen gilt und das
haben die betroffenen länder dann auch
anerkannt und sich dafür bedankt es gilt
dass die länder die weniger stark
betroffen sind wie zum beispiel hamburg
daneben auch im rahmen des möglichen
intensivpatienten übernehmen und sie
versorgen das ist das was wir als
aktiven nationalen kraftanstrengung und
solidarität bezeichnet haben das in den
hoch incidents ländern alles getan wird
um die infektions ausbreitung
einzudämmen und die weniger stark
betroffenen länder dann helfen dass die
gesundheitliche versorgung aller
menschen in deutschland gesichert ist
peter tschentscher war das der erste
bürgermeister der freien und hansestadt
hamburg hamburg hat natürlich mit dieser
konzentrierten fläche aber sehr früh den
weg frei gemacht für 2g und ist recht
gut damit gefahren und als mediziner der
auch teil war der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz und lange
monate in der pandemie als flitzer
agierte hat er immer ganz besonders in
dieser perspektive auch argumentiert so
auch jetzt hier bei dieser fragestellung
weiterhin halten wir den blick nach
schwerin das ist versprochen für sie
offen und auch in die verschiedenen
anderen landeshauptstädte wo wir noch
statements der entsprechenden
ministerpräsidenten und minister
präsidentinnen erwarten zum beispiel
rheinland pfalz malu dreyer aber auch
münchen markus söder zuvor wollen wir
ihnen nochmal falls sie nicht
gelegenheit hatten von anfang an
reinzuschauen nochmal die essenz aus der
pressekonferenz von angela merkel der
amtierenden bundeskanzlerin und den
chefs der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
und dem kanzlerkandidaten oder stolz
zeigen also nochmal die essenz angela
merkel oder scholz hier nochmal und
jederzeit live nach neue reaktionen
meine damen und herren wir haben in der
tat noch einmal beraten
und dies vor der situation dass die lage
in unserem land ernst ist was die
chorakademie anbelangt und
dass die belastung in den krankenhäusern
auch teilweise an die grenzen gerät wir
sehen das auch an der tatsache dass
patienten verlegt werden und deshalb
waren wir heute von einem akt der
nationalen solidarität gesprochen damit
wir sinkende infektionszahlen bekommen
und unser gesundheitssystem eben nicht
überlasten sondern entlasten in diesem
zusammenhang
ist auch noch einmal hier aufgeführt
unserem beschlusspapier was wir ihnen
schon berichtet hatten bezüglich des
krisenstabs und der imf ziele 30
millionen impfungen
angefangen zu rechnen vom 18 november
bis zum jahresende und dafür eben auch
die notwendigen organisatorischen
maßnahmen der impfstatus wird nicht
dauerhaft anerkannt werden können als
doppelt geimpft und damit abgeschlossen
sondern es wird ja auch auf der ebene
der eu diskutiert das noch neun monaten
der die zweite impfung ihrer gültigkeit
verliert das heißt dass boostern das
nach hinten das auf mischung simpson ist
ganz wichtig um dann als vollständig
games zu gelten aber natürlich werden
die übergangszeiten so sein dass jeder
auch eine chance hat seinen impfstatus
wieder zu erneuern
wir werden bundesweit einen zugang zu
einrichtungen und veranstaltungen der
kultur und freizeitgestaltung
unabhängig von der instanz nur für die
info lesende ermöglichen es kann
ergänzend auch ein test noch einmal 2d
plus genannt gefordert werden die 2g
regeln werden auch auf den einzelhandel
ausgeweitet ausgenommen sind die
geschäfte des täglichen bedarfs er soll
für alle privaten zusammenkünfte oder
kontakte dann eine strikte grenze geben
wenn sich ein nicht geimpfte personen
dabei befindet und zwar geht es da und
dann den eigenen haushalt sowie
höchstens zwei personen eines weiteren
haushalts also überall wo nicht alle
teilnehmer geimpft und genesen sind gilt
diese grenze eigene haushalts die
höchsten zwei weitere personen kinder
bis zur vollendung des 14 jahres sind
hiervon ausgenommen
wir haben es dann lange mit drei
überregionalen sport kultur in
vergleichbaren großveranstaltungen
beschäftigt vielleicht können die
ländervertreter dazu dann nachher etwas
sagen
spätestens ab einer inzidenz von mehr
als 350 neuinfektionen in sieben tagen
pro 100000 einwohner werden clubs und
diskotheken in innenräumen geschlossen
und
es ist dann auch so dass wir
sagen dass dies jetzt rechtlich schon
möglich wäre aber es wird noch einmal
gemeinsam vereinbart in kreisen mit
einer inzidenz oberhalb von 350 1 350
fällen pro 100.000 einwohner und sieben
tagen müssen alle kontakte reduziert
werden und deshalb gilt für private
feiern und zusammenkünfte eine
teilnehmer grenze von 50 personen also
geimpfte und genesene in innenräumen und
200 personen geimpft und genesene im
außenbereich für die die wohl ungeimpfte
dabei sind hatte ich ja erst ständig
maßgabe gesagt in schulen geht alle
masken pflicht eine strenge kontrolle
der regeln wird durchgesetzt und es geht
um die weiterentwicklung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes
das ist jetzt eine gesetzgebungsarbeit
die dann bis zum 15 dezember ja auch die
regelung ersetzen kann oder erweitern
kann die jetzt einen übergangszeitraum
hatten hierzu kann vielleicht auch noch
mal von olaf scholz etwas gesagt werden
weil das ja die gesetzgebung der
zukünftigen ampel koalition anbelangt
wir weisen noch darauf hin dass alle von
uns genannten maßnahmen quasi
mindeststandards sind das heißt länder
können strenger vorgehen und wir haben
uns noch einmal zur impfpflicht geäußert
eine allgemeine impfpflicht soll im
deutschen bundestag diskutiert und
entschieden werden dazu bitten bund und
länder den ethikrat sich bis jahresende
eine empfehlung zu erarbeiten und dann
kann diese
allgemeine impfpflicht könnte bei
entsprechender entscheidung greifen etwa
ab februar
2022 es wird ein expertengremium von
wissenschaftlern und wissenschaftlern
eingerichtet wir haben uns mit dem
silvester und neujahr beschäftigt das
würde ich auch hendrik wüst überlassen
und wir haben uns noch einmal zu den
wirtschafts hilfen verständigt
überbrückungshilfe 4 die natürlich
angesichts der einschränkungen von
großer bedeutung sind sie sehen an den
beschlüssen dass wir verstanden haben
dass die lage sehr ernst ist und dass
wir durch weitergehende maßnahmen
zusätzlich zu den jetzt schon
getroffenen maßnahmen im
infektionsschutzgesetz noch einmal dass
insbesondere auch in hoch inzidenz
gebieten handeln wollen um wirklich die
arbeit die stündlich und auch jetzt zu
dieser zeit wieder in den
intensivstationen geleistet wird nicht
nur anzuerkennen sondern möglichst auch
weniger notwendig zu machen und dazu
muss die vierte welle gebrochen werden
und das ist bis jetzt noch nicht
geschafft wir haben im augenblick eine
gewisse beruhigung aber auf einem viel
zu hohen niveau und deshalb waren diese
maßnahmen notwendig heute zu beschließen
wir sind in einer sehr sehr schwierigen
situationen wie alle wissen die hat
etwas damit zu tun dass wir zwar sehr
sehr viele geimpfte bürgern und bürger
haben aber nicht genügend viele um nicht
um sicherstellen zu können dass nicht
erneut sich an der infektionswelle durch
das land begibt das ist die situation
mit der wir konfrontiert sind und das
ist klar was wir als allererstes
erreichen müssen das müssen sich
diejenigen noch durch den sich im
zuzulassen dass bisher nicht gemacht
haben und das ist auch an dieser stelle
mein ganz persönlicher appell dass wir
alle überzeugen den schritt jetzt zu
gehen es ist wirklich wichtig und wir
wissen jetzt endgültig das ist eine
konsequenz hat dass ein großer teil der
bürger und bürger sich bisher nicht
durchgerungen hat sich impfen zu lassen
und wenn sich das jetzt ändern kann dann
wäre das sehr sehr wichtig für mich ist
das auch etwas das mit viel emotionen
verbunden ist denn wir wissen doch was
für
lagen auf den intensivstationen
entstehen wie schwierig das ist für die
arbeitskräfte dort für die pflegekräfte
für die ärzte und ärzte mit der lage
umzugehen damit umzugehen dass viele die
sich nicht haben impfen lassen dort
jetzt um ihr leben ringen und deshalb
müssen wir es schaffen dass wir die
situation ändern und das hat noch einmal
der erpel sich impfen zu lassen und für
uns alle gilt dass wir das ganz
ehrgeizige vorhaben jetzt in den
vordergrund stellen müssen viele
erstmalig zu impfen und viele die an der
impfung bereits haben mit einer
zusätzlichen schutz impfung zu versehen
dass boostern ist jetzt eine der ganz
ganz großen herausforderung ich darum
der krisenstab den general pro jahr
leiten wird darum aber auch das
ehrgeizige ziel wenn es denn irgendwie
erreichbar ist bis zu 30 millionen
impfungen alles zusammen zu erreichen
ist weihnachten und die kurze zeit
danach um zu erreichen dass dieser
schutz auch tatsächlich eintritt und wer
die wellen brechen können das ist eine
große logistische herausforderung man
sieht es an den fragen und den
schwierigkeiten die überall entstehen
wenn die ärzte und ärzten impfstoff
bestellen wenn überall neue impfzentren
eingerichtet werden die müssen jetzt
laufen das muss alles ineinandergreifen
und genau das haben wir uns vorgenommen
wir wissen das ist ein ehrgeiziges ziel
ist wenn man die verschiedenen impfungen
zusammenrechnet die da seid und der
letzten mpk und seit dem beschluss der
stiko dass alle sich
muss dann lassen sollen dass alle eine
auffrischungsimpfung bekommen sollen
seit dieser zeit auf den weg gebracht
haben aber diese kampagne muss jetzt
auch zu ende geführt werden und zwar mit
einem groß das nicht irgendwann sondern
ganz ganz kurzer zeit war das das
wichtigste mittel ist dass wir haben und
daneben brauchen wir natürlich viele
viele der schon genannten sehr
weitreichenden maßnahmen die dazu
beitragen dass die infektion sich nicht
ausbreiten können die beschränkung die
wir haben im bereich von gastronomie und
anderen bereichen für zusammenkünfte 2g
und 3g die beschränkungen im handel mit
2 gb ist jetzt neu ist ich glaube dass
das richtig und notwendig ist dass wir
auch im privaten bereich kontakt
beschränkung festlegen die eben sehr
streng sind wenn ungeimpfte bürgerinnen
und bürger dabei sind notwendigerweise
weil das ja eine der ursachen
desinfektions geschehens ist all die
anderen dinge sind genannt worden ich
glaube dass es wichtig ist dass wir klar
und präzise sind dass man sich geeinigt
hat und dass das dazu beitragen kann
dass wir jetzt eine bessere lage
bekommen ich bin froh dass der deutsche
bundestag bereits sich auf den weg
gemacht hat darüber zu beraten eine
einrichtungs bezogene im pflicht
einzuführen für
einrichtungen in dem besonders
schützenswerte bürgerinnen und bürger da
sind die diesen schutz auch verdient
haben und wofür alles dafür tun müssen
altenpflege einrichtungen und
krankenhäuser und dass wir eine offene
abstimmung im bundestag haben werden
über eine allgemeine impfpflicht der
anschlusses gegeben da glaube ich wird
es jetzt auch vorangehen und aus meiner
sicht sollte es auch zu anderen solchen
entscheidung des bundestages kommen ich
bin auch ziemlich sicher dass das der
fall sein wird neben dem krisenstab der
das impf und postern begleitend dafür
sorgt dass alles gut funktioniert wollen
wir uns auch regelmäßig neu beraten
lassen deshalb ein expertenrat von
wissenschaftlern und wissenschaftlern
dem eingerichtet wird und er natürlich
nicht nur die bundesregierung und den
bundestag sondern auch die
ministerpräsident und
ministerpräsidenten mit rat und
vorschlägen versehen soll aber es sollen
vorschläge seien die gemeinsam
erarbeitet worden sind die diskutiert
worden sind nicht dass in 15
verschiedenen nebeneinander stehen
sondern etwas wo man sich
auseinandersetzen kann und muss dass wir
alles dafür tun dass diese situation
besser wird das ist das was hier
gemeinsam sich alle vorgenommen haben
und ich bin froh dass in dieser
schwierigen lage der schulterschluss
funktioniert dass die parteipolitik in
den hintergrund
die gesundheit der bürgerinnen und
bürger in den vordergrund des
gemeinsamen politischen bestrebens so
soll es die nächste zeit auch weiter
sein es geht um eine große nationale
anstrengung und es geht um solidarität
und so weiter olaf scholz nach der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
der künftige bundeskanzler deutschlands
meine damen und herren wir halten
weiterhin blick offen in alle föderalen
licht richtungen in deutschland wir
haben ihn schon hamburg gezeigt wir
haben in den süden geschaut ins saarland
wir haben einen blick nach mecklenburg
vorpommern da haben wir auch die
vorschau die wir eben schon kurz gezeigt
haben über jetzt hier nochmal bringen
könnte erwarten die manuela schwesig
gleichzeitig wissen wir dass auch in
mainz in rheinland pfalz die dortigen
ministerpräsidenten malu dreyer vor hat
sich nochmal zu den ergebnissen zu
äußern und wir wissen auch dass das
ganze vor hat daniel günther in kiel der
ministerpräsident von schleswig-holstein
also dieses roundup versuchen wir ihnen
anzubieten in der zwischenzeit können
wir ihnen zeigen sozusagen die
länderseite nach dem ende dieser
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz die nämlich
wirklich in persona im vorsitz in berlin
teilgenommen hat der vorsitz der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
liegt ja bei hendrik wüst
ministerpräsident nordrhein westfalen
und der stellvertreter ist michael
müller regierender bürgermeister von
berlin henrik wüst macht den anfang und
wir gucken jederzeit nach draußen gehen
dorthin
im namen der ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten der länder möchte
ich mich an erster stelle mal ganz
herzlich bei all denen bedanken die mit
ihrer solidarität helfen dass wir gut
durch die krise kommen und gleichzeitig
alle nicht geimpften dringend aufrufen
die impf angebote wahrzunehmen nicht
erst irgendwann vielleicht im neuen jahr
oder nach weihnachten sondern jetzt sie
retten damit leben unser land ist
weiterhin in einer schwierigen lage es
liegen auch schwierige wochen noch vor
uns die infektionszahlen sind weiterhin
hoch zu hoch ärzte pflegekräfte sind am
limit und arbeiten teilweise schon lange
darüber hinaus wir haben mit omikron
eine neue gefährliche mutation im land
um das nehmen wir sehr ernst die
ministerpräsidenten von sachsen und
baden württemberg wir haben heute
eindrücklich die lage dargestellt die in
teilen unseres landes eben nicht nur
kritisch ist sondern dramatisch seit dem
zweiten weltkrieg hatten wir in
deutschland keine vergleichbare
situation im gesundheitswesen wir
brauchen deshalb einen akt der
nationalen solidarität das heißt erstens
wir müssen in den nächsten wochen
konsequent kontakte reduzieren nur so
kann diese vierte welle gebrochen werden
und zweitens impfen impfen ist der weg
raus aus dieser schwierigen lage in der
pandemien deshalb müssen sich alle
impfen lassen die sich impfen lassen
können es ist richtig und es ist wichtig
und ist heute auch wirklich gut gewesen
dass wir länder mit dem bund eine
gemeinsame linie abgestimmt haben jetzt
gemeinsam konsequent handeln die erneute
ein umfangreiches paket
beschlossen
umfangreiche kontakt beschränkungen für
ungeimpfte deutliche reduktion der
zuschauer bei überregionalen
großveranstaltung das gilt auch für
spiele der fußball bundesliga clubs und
diskotheken werden in vielen
bundesländern geschlossen 2g regeln
werden ausgeweitet die wir an dieser
stelle ausdrücklich betonen dass sind
mindeststandards im übrigen haben wir
auch noch mal das feuerwerksverbot fürs
jahresende aus dem letzten jahr
wiederholt auch dass ein mindest
standard in den betroffenen regionen in
den besonders stark betroffenen regionen
gelten selbstverständlich deutlich
strengere regeln gerade in den hotspots
brauchen die verantwortlichen zur
pandemie bekämpfung zusätzliche optionen
das ist auch in den letzten tagen von
vielen kolleginnen und kollegen deutlich
gemacht worden ist deshalb gut dass herr
scholz für die künftige regierung für
die mehrheit im deutschen bundestag
erklärt hat dass er bereit ist
nachzubessern aus interaktion
schutzgesetz des bundes zu überarbeiten
es ist eben besonders wichtig für die
länder mit besonders hohen
infektionszahlen ist die ziffer 14 in
dem beschlusspapier indem der
gesetzgeber gebeten wird das
infektionsschutzgesetz und weitere
regelungen zu ergänzen damit länder und
regionen mit einem besonders hohen
infektionsgeschehen weiterhin
angemessene zusätzliche angebot aber
maßnahmen zum schutz der bevölkerung zur
verfügung haben und darüber hinaus wird
der gesetzgeber gebeten die
übergangsfristen für schutzmaßnahmen im
infektionsschutzgesetz die bis zum 25 in
kraft getreten sind über den 15 dezember
hinaus zu verlängern und es wird
gesetzlich klargestellt dass diese
maßnahmen auch regional differenziert
angeordnet werden können das ist ganz
ganz wichtig für regionen mit besonders
hohen infektionszahlen ich bin dankbar
dass das möglich ist dieser winter
könnte härter werden als alles andere
was wir bisher in der pandemie erlebt
haben ihr könnt der härter werden werden
wir nicht weiter entschlossen eingreifen
und handeln wir haben das in den letzten
monaten bewiesen dass wir das können
dass wir eingreifen gerade auch in den
letzten wochen haben viele länder ja
schon durch die maßnahmen die wir
ergriffen haben auch verhindern können
dass diese fördert situation weiter
eskaliert oder sie haben es sogar schon
erreicht dass es einen leichten rückgang
desinfektions geschehens gibt will auch
betonen dass auch auf der bundesebene
das passiert ist es wird sehr viel
natürlich darüber gesprochen und
berichtet dass die notlage aufgegeben
wurde durch die entscheidung des
deutschen bundestages aber einhergehend
damit waren weitere massive
möglichkeiten einzugreifen wenn man
alleine an der iss an die 3g regelung am
arbeitsplatz denkt oder auch die
entsprechenden home office regeln sie
sind mit beschlossen worden von der
bundesebene und sind weitere wichtige
instrumente im kampf gegen die pandemie
auch für die länder wir haben heute auch
wieder miteinander wichtige maßnahmen
beschlossen die eben schon dargestellt
wurden und ich glaube dass es uns damit
auch gelingen kann dass sich die
situation auf den intensivstationen
nicht weiter zuspitzt denn dass es ja
nach wie vor das maß der dinge denn
gesundheitsschutz sicherzustellen und
auch dafür zu sorgen dass unsere
kliniken weiter leistungsfähig sind und
die schwerstkranken gut versorgen können
ich bin sehr froh dass einige dinge die
auch in den ländern auch bei uns in
berlin schon eine rolle spielen jetzt
auch bundesweit verabredet werden
konnten wie zum beispiel auch die 2g
regel einzelhandel keine einfache
situation für die einzelhändlerin und
einzelhändler das weiß ich die
reaktionen sind auch entsprechend in
berlin aber wir erleben eben auch die
reaktion der kunden die sagen sie finden
es richtig und gut dass so eingegriffen
wird und dass es solche regeln gibt weil
sie sich sicherer fühlen weil sie merken
dass es schützt also insofern konnten
wir auch auf diese erfahrung jetzt gut
aufbauen auch andere dinge
einschränkungen bei veranstaltungen zum
beispiel oder überhaupt das umsetzen der
zweig regel ja praktisch in so gut wie
allen lebensbereichen sind denke ich
wichtige maßnahmen man muss es immer
wieder sagen dass es besonders wichtig
ist auch auf die ungeimpften hier zu
reagieren die ungeimpften machen nun mal
den großteil der infektion und den stil
schweren fälle auch aus das bedeutet
dass eine gruppe die deutlich in der
minderheit das wir haben inzwischen
bundesweit eine über 70 prozent die
impfquote das heißt dass eine gruppe die
deutlich in der minderheit es eben die
ungeimpften für die deutliche mehrheit
der infektionen verantwortlich ist und
darauf muss man reagieren
und ich finde es richtig dass wir
jenseits der frage der partiellen oder
allgemeine impfpflicht jetzt auch
wirklich an einem punkt sind wo das
spürbar ist dass wir darauf reagieren
dass die die die mehrheit darstellen die
vernünftig sind di
verantwortungsbewusst angebote
angenommen haben nämlich die geimpften
dass die möglichkeiten haben die anderen
nicht haben das spiegelt sich auch heute
in unseren verabredungen und in unseren
beschlüssen wieder
letztendlich nicht abschließend aber
auch sagen
alles was wir miteinander beschließen
löst nicht die situation auf dass jeder
auch eigenverantwortlich handeln muss
jeder kann eigenverantwortlich handeln
von institutionen angefangen soll ich an
der stelle auch mal sind weit entfernt
von einem wirklichen lockdown wir haben
einschränkungen beschlossen aber wir
ermöglichen auch immer noch länger aber
wir ermöglichen dinge wo ein mindest
standard formuliertes und jede
institution für sich auch gruppen kann
kann man nicht noch mehr machen im
übrigen kann auch ein fußball verein mit
seinen fans kontakt aufnehmen und sagen
wir
spielen mit deutlich reduzierter
zuschauerzahl oder vielleicht auch ganz
ohne zuschauer weil uns der
infektionsschutz so wichtig ist dass es
nicht verboten für ein fußball verein so
eine initiative zu ergreifen
genausowenig verboten wie auch für
andere institutionen
und mir begegnet in den letzten tagen
ist auch immer wieder dass menschen auf
mich zukommen und sagen ihr schließt da
immer weitere einschränkungen wie wird
denn das kontrolliert es wird doch nicht
funktionieren ohne kontrolle muss
zugeben dass ich ein bisschen staunen
über diese diskussionen weil es so gut
wie keinen lebensbereich gibt in dem wir
uns bewegen wo wir uns nicht auf
grundlage von regeln bewegen die wir
gelernt haben von denen wir wissen dass
sie uns schützen uns und andere schützen
wir beachten sie ohne dass sie lückenlos
kontrolliert werden und wir alle halten
an einer roten ampel und wir wissen das
nicht neben jeder ampel ein polizist
steht der kontrolliert ob wir anhalten
aber wir haben gelernt dass es uns und
andere schützt dass es sicherer ist an
einer roten ampel zu halten warum ist
das eigentlich nicht so
selbstverständlich nach den letzten
anderthalb jahren corona pandemie
möglich also insofern
sage ich ja die politik bleibt in einer
verantwortung rahmenbedingungen zu
setzen das ist unsere aufgabe
und wir kommen dieser aufgabe auch nach
bund wie länder aber es kommt gerade
vielleicht auch für die nächsten monate
noch mal darauf an bis wir eine noch
deutlich höhere impfquote haben auch mit
der durchsetzung der impfpflicht es
kommt für die nächsten monate auch noch
mal auf eigene verantwortung an es gibt
ganz viele die so eigenverantwortlich
schon gehandelt haben in den letzten
monaten und ich hoffe dass es auch in
den nächsten wochen und monaten immer
mehr tun werden weil sie im wissen wie
wichtig es für unser zusammenleben in
einer solidargemeinschaft ist genau auf
solche regeln die uns und andere
schützen auch zu achten
michael möller war das stellvertretender
vorsitzender der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
regierender bürgermeister von berlin als
sozialdemokrat gerade in den neuen
deutschen bundestag eingezogen für den
21 dezember übrigens wird die nachfolge
bei ihm in berlin erwartet das bild von
der roten ampel ist ganz schön über das
man tunlichst nicht fahren soll oder
über die man tunlichst nicht fahren soll
aber in der tat gibt es halt immer
wieder diese übertretung insofern müssen
wir dass das impfen in deutschland
angeht offenbar noch sehr viel mehr
überzeugungsarbeit leisten punkt eins
und möglicherweise auch druck ausüben
genau das hat heute die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz in ihren
beschlüssen für bundesweite regelungen
auf den weg gebracht was wir ihnen hier
zeigen und was sie jetzt hinter mir
sehen sind die verschiedenen reaktionen
aus den ländern das hier direkt hinter
mir was jetzt im vollen bild sehen wie
wir das bezeichnen hebel fernsehen in
folge ist rheinland pfalz dort wird sich
in wenigen minuten äußern malu dreyer
die ministerpräsidentin des bundeslandes
gleichzeitig haben sie termine und
vormerkungen für weitere bundesländer
unter anderem haben wir ein bild
vorliegen aus dem kleinen bremen der
hansestadt wo sich andreas bovenschulte
äußern möchte auch in den nächsten
minuten wir haben ein bild wenn wir
weiterhin im norden bleiben aus
schleswig-holstein da tut sich immer mal
ein bisschen was weil das ein raum ist
der landespressekonferenz wo auch immer
mal einer hin- und hergeht aber sie
sehen sozusagen hier die räumlichkeiten
in kiel
gleichzeitig warten wir noch auf bilder
aus münchen markus söder hat sich dort
geäußert und liegt jetzt gleich vor und
wir sind auf jeden fall am ball wann
immer etwas leicht passiert aber markus
söder bayerischer ministerpräsident
wer hat tatsächlich auch noch mal mit
ihm pflicht vorschlägen heute nochmal
furore gemacht in richtung impfpflicht
auch für kinder das ist natürlich so
nicht beschieden worden aber es bleibt
in der debatte er hat jetzt noch einmal
erklärt dass er durchaus auch die
empfehlung des ethikrates zum jahresende
abwarten will aber hier das statement
von markus söder direkt nach dem ende
der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
man ist sehr verehrten damen und herren
schönen guten tag wir haben heute eine
sehr konstruktive runde erlebt mit einem
gemeinsamen willen die pandemie zu
bekämpfen alle waren sich einig der
kampf gegen korona hat oberste priorität
in deutschland wir haben ja in bayern
schon gehandelt und vieles von dem was
dort beschlossen wurde eigentlich
vorweggenommen das was wir tun wirkt man
kann das wirklich für bayern sagen die
zahlen gehen jetzt doch deutlich runter
zwar langsam aber sie gehen runter wir
haben jetzt fast 70 80 incidents punkte
senken können das heißt der trend stimmt
wir sind immer das einzige bundesland
das eine so starken rückgang hat im
vergleich zu allen anderen bleiben auf
platz 5 insgesamt trotzdem ist es immer
noch viel zu hoch kein anlass zur
entwarnung sondern eher ansporn
weiterzumachen konsequentes war zu
setzen denn die intensivstationen sind
nach wie vor maximal belastet und man
muss immer davon ausgehen dass die
residenz zeigen sich zwei wochen später
auch in den krankenhäusern widerspiegeln
so dass der mit erheblichen nach
weiteren belastungen zu rechnen ist
deswegen ist die bekämpfung der pandemie
und das nicht nachlassen im kampf
dagegen eine zentrale aufgabe in
deutschland erfahren auch der
bayerischen staatsregierung die heutigen
beschlüsse er verändern vorbei nicht
viel aber sind doch an einigen stellen
sehr sehr wichtig das erste was glaube
ich das entscheidende war dass bundes
infektionsschutz wird gesetzt wird noch
einmal nachgebessert und geändert das
ist die zusage des bundes zwar in welche
richtung zum einen ein mal dass bayern
die möglichkeit hat wie andere
bundesländer beispielsweise sachsen die
beschlossenen maßnahmen auch jenseits
des 15 12 zu setzen das heißt wir sind
da nicht wehrlos sondern können bei
hotspots und anderen bereichen
entsprechend reagieren und auch die
grundlegenden maßnahmen machen sie sehen
gerade in den hohen belasteten regionen
in bayern hat mir noch vor zehn tagen
über 10 also elf über 1000 jetzt sind es
nur noch vier also der trend ist da
eindeutig positiv für uns wichtig es
gibt aber auch noch zusatz möglichkeiten
die man angehen kann es geht nicht nur
die verlängerung sondern zusatz
möglichkeiten werden erlaubt
alkoholverbote können gemacht werden
genauso wie an sammlungs einschränkungen
deswegen ist es für uns zunächst mal das
allerwichtigste die zusage auch der
neuen mehrheit in berlin dass man
verlängert und neue instrumente schafft
damit können die länder und damit kann
auch bayern in der notlage reagieren
zweitens die strategie definiert sich
über zwei zusätzliche elemente der
lockdown vergeben ungeimpfte und das
massive boostern und die impfpflicht
zunächst zum lockdown für ungeimpfte da
er 90 prozent derer die auf
intensivstationen sind ungeimpfte sind
und auch die höchst infektionszahlen
dort stattfindet muss man hier ansetzen
zentral sind aber die kontakt
beschränkung und die werden jetzt
reduziert bei ungeimpften auf maximal
ein haushalt plus zwei personen aus
einem anderen haushalt dies bedeutet und
wir werden es dann in bayern umsetzen
eine einschränkung eine weitere
einschränkungen für die kontakte dies
gilt übrigens auch wenn ein ungeimpfter
auf mehrere geimpfte trifft immer dann
wenn ein um gamestar quasi sich mit
jemand anders trifft maximal zwei
personen haushalt auch wenn es geimpfte
sein soll dies ist die neue regel das
bedeutet natürlich eine einschränkung
aber gleichzeitig auf eine motivation
sich impfen zu lassen
für die geimpften selber gibt es keine
kontakt beschränkungen das einzige was
heute auf den weg gebracht wurde und es
eigentlich selbstverständlich dass wir
insbesondere in den hoch belasteten
gebieten dringend abraten auch größere
feiern zu machen insbesondere wegen der
gefahr von impfstoff brücken wir sind
jetzt mitten in der phase des postens
des rings soll ja gesagt werden solche
zusammentreffen seien maximal für 50
personen
möglich dies gilt aber nicht für den
bereich von kultur und kino denn da ist
ganz normal zweig plus mit maximal 25
prozent auslastung aber generell wenn es
eine private zusammenkunft auch von
geimpft
[Applaus]
für die zuschauer zuschauer das ist um
des sonnensegels jetter wird weil es
doch einige sonnenstrahlen offenkundig
wieder über bayern gibt
[Applaus]
zu feiern also nochmal maximal überhaupt
besten gar keine zu machen aber wenn
sich die impfte treffen wollen zu einer
feier dann maximal 50 personen
mehr sollte das dann nicht sein an der
stelle aber wir raten er von jeder form
von feier ab weil es schwierig ist
2g im handel davon ist ausgenommen der
tägliche bedarf auch dies wird jetzt neu
sein den wir umsetzen werden zum impfen
das impfbuch dann soll vorangebracht
werden es sollen bis weihnachten so ist
der nationale paraden plan bis zu 30
millionen impfungen verabreicht werden
dies ist ganz zentral dazu brauchen wir
vor allen dingen impfstoff dies ist die
kernaufgabe der neuen regierung das
impfstoff management zu schaffen damit
schnell ausreichend und voraus stunden
impfstoff verteilt wird dazu eben auch
mehrere im kapazitäten nicht nur die
ärzte sondern auch der weitere ausbau 15
sind und ganz besonders wichtig auch
apotheken apothekerinnen sollen die
möglichkeit jetzt bekommen zu impfen das
gesetz wird geändert und
alle haben sich dafür ausgesprochen für
eine impfpflicht wir machen diese
impfpflicht nicht etwa nicht
nachdenklich sondern es genau abgewogen
überlegt weil wir sonst nicht aus dieser
kroner endlosschleife herauskommen und
in einem jahr bei neuen mutationen und
bei einer nicht zu steigenden zahl der
geimpften möglicherweise nicht
weiterkommen deswegen abwägend aber alle
sind sich einig sie wollen eine
impfpflicht und ich begrüße ausdrücklich
dass heute morgen auch die fdp christian
lindner gesagt habe auch in seiner
abwägung ist er jetzt dafür das ganze
hilft wichtig ist wer und wie auch
welche altersgruppen da haben uns jetzt
zwar verständlich sollte ethikrat einen
vorschlag machen teilt ist richtig ich
bin da offen in allen bereichen hinein
ich finde es gut wenn aber am ende
abschließend der ethikrat einen
vorschlag macht wehr und biss ins welche
alter gemacht wird wenn wir aber nicht
haben das ist glaube ich notwendig diese
konsequent umzusetzen
einen wermutstropfen gibt es allerdings
bei der heutigen besprechung was ich
schade finde es gab keine endgültige
einigung beim fußball jedenfalls keine
die wirksam ist dort schwankte sehr mit
den möglichkeiten und
bayern sachsen und baden württemberg
auch andere haben nachdrücklich dafür
geworben
keine zuschauer in die stadien zu
bringen warum fußball ist eine
überregionale großveranstaltung fans
bewegen sich durch ganz deutschland und
zwar aus gebiet mit hoch incidents im
gebiet ried mit lieblich incidents wir
bleiben dabei erhalten geisterspiele für
sinnvoller und dann ist auch morgen im
bayerischen kabinett so wird mein
vorschlag seien dann umsetzen warum
einfach weil es nicht vorstellbar ist
dass weihnachtsmärkte nicht stattfinden
und große stadien ausgelastet sind und
selbst wenn es in ein riesen staaten wie
in münchen hier bei uns in allianz
rennen nur 12 13 14.000 zuschauer sind
es ist an der stelle zu viel bewegung in
kontakt und es ist auch ein systembruch
gegenüber anderen fragen veranstalter
mit beispielsweise der weihnachtsmärkte
ich finde es schade und auch schlecht
dass wir uns da nicht darauf einigen
können dass einige bundesländer
zuschauer erlauben wollen
positiv in das ist wieder und hat sich
auf eine gemeinsame regelung für
silvester geeinigt im grunde genommen
wie letztes jahr es gibt die möglichkeit
ein amüsantes und versammlungsverbot zu
machen es soll ein feuerwerksverbot
seien auf öffentlichen plätzen diese
entscheiden dann die kommunen das war
letztes jahr auch ganz entscheidend wenn
sie im wald das so zusammen machen
würden ist es ja das anderssein und sie
sind als wenn sie an öffentlichen
plätzen sitter bis der infekt logisches
problem und es wird ein verbot geben des
verkaufs von pyrotechnik das wird
gemacht werden ersatz soll ist
allerdings dafür geben als hilfe für die
betroffenen firmen genauso wie eine
ausgeweitete hilfe und verstärkt hilfe
für schausteller die von den
weihnachtsmärkten zungen sehr getroffen
sind und für diskus und club betreiber
bereits morgen früh über das bayerische
kabinett tagen und wird dann die
entsprechenden beschlüsse umsetzen wie
gesagt für uns ist es nicht viel
änderung es ist kontakt beschränkung ist
zweig im wesentlichen und natürlich die
umsetzung der geisterspiele die wir dann
morgen machen können wir werden morgen
auch noch mal über die situation der
schulen und kitas reden wie es da
weitergeht insbesondere deswegen was
positiv ist wir konnten heute auf
unseren vorschlag hin durchsetzen an den
masten protest nicht für ganz
deutschland schulen zu machen und jetzt
soll noch mal über die situation an
bayerischen schulen und kitas
ausführlich beraten
zum schluss noch ein dank von meiner
seite dank an die kolleginnen und
kollegen ist fußball
die bundeskanzlerin die heute ihre
letzte das war jetzt tatsächlich die
letzte gemeinsame runde wir haben glaube
ich zwei dreimal sie in der mp runde
verabschiedet aber die not hat eben
einfach immer wieder zusammengeführt
heute ist es definitiv das letzte mal
werden sie glaube ich sehr vermissen
deswegen auch noch mal herzlichen dank
an der stelle auch von bayerische
staatsregierung mir ganz persönlich
danken erzielbaren olaf scholz man hat
schon gemerkt es waren viele einigen
möglich weil da auch die erfahrungen der
wunsch dabei war zur gemeinsamen lösung
zu kommen mein größter dank gilt aber im
moment und er ist verbunden mit der
bitte das auch weiter zu machen an die
bayerische bevölkerung
wir spüren die bereitschaft mitzumachen
hat sich deutlich erhöht und ich glaube
auch dass ein teil der zahlen nicht nur
runtergeht weil die maßnahmen wirken
sondern weil die menschen und zum land
mit machen dafür möchte ich mich ganz
persönlich aber auch namen der
staatsregierung und auch im namen der
pflegekräfte bedanken die so stark
belastet sind an sie richtet sich dann
auch noch mal mein besonderer dank und
auch mal
meinen wunsch durchzuhalten wie war noch
mal zu überlegen was wir noch machen
können um die pflege zu starten um noch
mit finanziellen möglichkeiten wirklich
jedem zu motivieren mitzumachen weil das
natürlich leider ein teil der
schwierigen lage ist die pflegekräfte in
bayern auch die mediziner leisten echt
großartige arbeit mein tiefen dank unter
die feste zusage dass wir nicht
dringende pflegereform brauchen die am
ende zu mehr akzeptanz bereitschaft und
motivation aller für die pflege sind
meine damen und herren so weit die
einschätzungen von markus söder
ministerpräsident von bayern nach dem
ende der ministerpräsidenten-konferenz
wir gehen jetzt ein haus weiter schauen
in den norden und bieten ihnen live
jetzt diese einschätzungen
getroffen
nachdem wir bereits am dienstag in einem
informellen format über leitlinien der
neuen pandemie regelung beraten hatten
konkrete hintergrund ist dass
insbesondere im süden und osten der
republik eine überlastung des
gesundheitssystems droht oder schon
eingetreten ist und auch im übrigen
bundesgebiet die situation zumindest uns
sehr schwierig ist wenn wir bereits in
den vergangenen tagen intensiv patienten
aus sachsen aufgenommen
andere länder haben das auch gemacht und
das zeigt dass zeit für entschlossenes
und klares handeln ist wir haben uns
heute sowohl auf bundesweit einheitliche
maßnahmen zum teil incidence unabhängig
verständigt und andererseits auf
maßnahmen für hoch incidents gebiete
denn ganz klar ist was ich auch in den
vergangenen tagen immer gesagt habe für
eine region wie in schleswig holstein
mit 950 er incident kann ich das gleiche
gelten wie für eine region mit einer
incidents von 1200 wie in sachsen
sondern da muss es auch differenzierte
regelung geben
wir haben uns darauf verständigt dass
die impf anstrengungen deutlich
verstärkt werden müssen das will ich
gleich an den anfang stellen bekommen
bevor ich zu dem bundesweit
einheitlichen maßnahmen die darüber
hinausgehen komme unser hotspot
strategie wir werden eine einrichtung
bezogene impfpflicht auf den weg bringen
dass es keine große leuchte das ist
heute noch mal bestätigt worden
altenheimer pflegeheime krankenhäuser
und ähnliche einrichtungen
wir haben noch einmal begrüßt dass wir
oder wir haben begrüßt dass der
bundestag zeitnah über eine allgemeine
impfpflicht entscheiden wird dass es
auch keine große neuigkeit
es besteht weitgehend einigkeit dass
auch eine allgemeine impfpflicht kommen
sollen allerdings
noch unklarheit darüber wie die im
einzelnen ausgestaltet werden soll wir
noch mal bekräftigt dass bis weihnachten
bis zu 30 millionen impfungen
durchgeführt werden müssen wenn man
wirklich sehr zeitnah die
anspruchsberechtigten boostern möchte
und auch weiter fortschritte bei den
erst- und zweitwohnungen machen möchte
und zu diesem zweck haben wir uns heute
auch dafür ausgesprochen den kreis der
personen die impfen dürfen noch einmal
deutlich auszuweiten auf apothekerinnen
und apotheker zahnärztinnen und
zahnärzte und auch eine delegation auf
entsprechend geschulte pflegekräfte zu
ermöglichen soweit zum impfen zu den
bundesweit einheitlichen maßnahmen wie
es sich schon abgezeichnet hatte wird
die 2g regel auf dem einzelhandel
ausgeweitet es gibt ausnahmen für die
geschäfte des täglichen bedarfs und da
orientieren wir uns ausdrücklich an der
ausnahmeliste der bundes notbremse die
wir ja zur mitte des jahres oder im
ersten quartal dieses jahres verlassen
hatten da gibt es eine ganze reihe von
geschäften die definiert sind als
geschäfte des täglichen bedarfs und die
ausnahmeregel für die bereiche für die
die zweijährige gilt soll sich auch
daran orientieren und das werden wir in
bremen auch machen die zweijährige für
den einzelhandel ist incidents
unabhängig
und das heißt sie wird dann auch
bundesweit einheitlich so umgesetzt
werden unabhängig vom konkreten
infektionsgeschehen das gleiche gilt für
die 2g regel beim zugang zu
einrichtungen und veranstaltungen der
kultur der freizeit kinos gaststätten
theater und so weiter und so fort auch
da wird die 2g rege allgemein gelten
zusätzlich kann bei rom
infektionsgeschehen auch noch mit 2g
plus regel dazu geschaltet also können
auch noch tests verlangt werden wir
haben uns auf strenge kontakt
beschränkung für ungeimpfte verständigt
private zusammenkünfte an denen nicht
ausschließlich geimpft und gemessene
teilnehmen sollen künftig auf den
eigenen haushalt sowie höchstens zwei
personen eines weiteren haushaltes
beschränkt sein wobei kinder bis 14
jahre ausgenommen sein sollen damit man
das umsetzen kann gibt es noch bestimmte
änderungen im bundesrechtlich
vorgenommen werden müssen deshalb müssen
wir mal gucken wie schnell wir da in der
umsetzung in unserer landesverordnung
sind
überregionale sport kultur und
vergleichbare großveranstaltungen werden
deutlich eingeschränkt das gilt
bundeseinheitlich auch unabhängig von
der instanz in geschlossenen räumen
maximal 50%
kapazitätsausbau kosten 5000 zuschauer
im freien auch 50 prozent kapazität von
maximal und mit einer höchst größe von
höchst zahl von 15.000 zuschauern es
sind medizinische masken zu tragen und
natürlich ist auch da die zweige
einzuhalten zu den besonderheiten für
hoch incidents gebiete komme ich gleich
noch
unberührt davon das will ich einfach nur
der sicherheitshalber nochmal sagen
bleibt die für das morgige heimspiel von
werder gefundene
einzelfallregelung da hatte ich ja auch
gestern gesagt und so haben wir das mit
dem verein auch verständigt da müssen
wir eine einzelfallregelung treffen und
konnten nicht auf die regelung heute
warten das wäre sonst einfach zu kurz
gewesen zu kurzfristigen zum
kommunizieren
nächste punkt in schulen gilt eine
masten pflicht für eine klassenstufen
von der ersten bis zur 13 wo es sie gibt
auch im unterricht
das ist eine abweichung von der
bisherigen bremer position ich habe
meine skepsis dazu noch einmal
vorgetragen aber
es gab dann klare mehrheit dafür masten
pflicht für alle klassenstufen habe dann
noch mal angeregt wenn man das aus
infektionsschutz gründen für notwendig
hält
dass man so eine strikte masken pflicht
in schulen macht dass man eine
vergleichbar strikte masken vielleicht
auch in der arbeitswelt für erwachsenen
einführt
die ist deutlich milder bist ja die
masken flüchtende arbeitswelt in der
korona arbeitsschutzverordnung geregelt
da gibt es jede menge ausnahmen von der
masken pflicht und ich habe gesagt wenn
wir jetzt eine strikte haben in den
schulen überall in jeder klasse und im
unterricht dann bräuchten und auch eine
strikte in der arbeitswelt wenn mehr als
eine person in einem raum sich aufhält
das haben allerdings die kolleginnen und
kollegen anders bisher mussten zwischen
kindern und jugendlichen einerseits und
erwachsenen differenzieren
ja was auch noch geschlossen wurde
bundesweit einheitlich verkauf von
pyrotechnik wird vor silvester verboten
und es gibt ein feuerwerksverbot auf die
kommunen definierten plätzen und es gibt
auch ein sammlungsverbot silvester und
neujahr so wie letztes jahr auch und so
wie letztes jahr hatte ich mich dann
auch mit dafür eingesetzt dass wir eine
klausel kriegen dass die hersteller von
pyrotechnik entsprechend kompensiert
werden das betrifft ja auch ein
unternehmen in bremerhaven insbesondere
das waren die bundesweit einheitliche
maßnahmen
zusätzlich wurde eine hotspot strategie
mit maßnahmen beschlossen die im hoch
incidents gebieten gelten sollen wobei
als hoch ins gebet immer benannt wurde
eine region ein kreis ein land mit einer
instanz über 350 und für die gilt
private feiern und private
veranstaltungen
über beim bei einer instanz über 350
müssen teilnehmer beschränkt
durchgeführt werden maximal 50 personen
in rund 200 personen draußen also das
würde für geburtstage hochzeiten oder
ähnliches gelten bei sieben tagen über
350 wenn clubs und diskotheken in
innenräumen geschlossen
wenn man keine wenn man unter den 350
licht clubs und diskotheken natürlich
zweig oder wie in bremen bei einer
höheren warnstufe auch vorgesehen zweig
plus schließung aber erst hat 350er
incidents im hoch incidents gebeten
sollen sportveranstaltung ich hatte ja
vorher schon die allgemeinen
höchstgrenzen genannten möglichst ohne
zuschauer durchgeführt werden und
veranstaltungen generell abgesagt werden
großveranstaltungen jetzt das ist ein
bisschen weich formuliert nicht ganz hat
aber schon eine klare leitlinie das in
einem buch incidents gebet natürlich
eine veranstaltung mit 15.000 zuschauern
draußen oder 5000 drin nicht die
geeignete größe ist sondern wie gesagt
nach möglichkeit ohne zuschauer
durchgeführt werden soll oder abgesagt
werden soll und den hoch incidents
gebeten sollen weitere maßnahmen möglich
seien schließung von gaststätten verbot
von alkohol ab
einschränkung von hotelübernachtungen
dann gibt es auch noch diskussionen
darüber wie das jetzt im bundesgesetz
verankert wird da war noch so kleine
debatte
das kann auch noch zur diskussion führen
weil besonders betroffene länder gesagt
haben wir brauchen doch die instrumente
und richtig schwierige lage zu
bewältigen und dazu kann auch richtig
können auch richtig scharfe eingriffe
gehören und die muss es dann ja auch im
bundesgesetz geben als
ermächtigungsgrundlage
und die bundesregierung hat gesagt ja
wenn das notwendig ist gucken wir uns
das an und dann gehen wir auch davon aus
dass der bundestag die entsprechenden
gesetzlichen änderungen vornimmt
da wird es noch so ein bisschen
glaube ich knirschen und reiben bis man
sich da vollständig verständigt hat
andreas schulte war dass bürgermeister
von bremen sozialdemokrat also ein wenig
feintuning ist noch möglich und vor
allen dingen notwendig nach den
ergebnissen der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz bei der
scheidenden bundeskanzlerin schon in
anwesenheit ihres mutmaßlichen
nachfolgers olaf scholz die ganz klare
botschaft lautet zweig dort wo es
möglich ist und zwar als bundesweite
variante aber auch masken pflicht an
schulen bundesweit und schafe
einschränkungen für ungeimpfte
tatsächlich auch bei bestimmten
instanzen auch die schließung von clubs
und diskotheken dass es so zu sagen so
der kernpunkt dessen worauf man sich
geeinigt hat aber auch eine bezogene
impfpflicht auf
bestimmte bereiche die allgemeine
impfpflicht soll zunächst einmal geprüft
werden dass sozusagen die essenz dieses
nachmittages wir gehen ein haus weiter
bleiben aber im norden schleswig
holstein das tatsächlich so zu sagen
sehr freundliche instanzen aufzuweisen
hat hat ministerpräsident daniel günther
an der spitze der nächstes jahr
landtagswahlen zu bestehen hat und seine
sicht auf die ergebnisse der mpk sehen
sie jetzt die
heute konferenz der
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten
hatten wir haben über die verabredung
von dienstag gesprochen und über die
konkreten umsetzung dazu haben wir
gemeinsame beschlüsse gefasst und es ist
ein bundesweit einheitliches vorgehen
wichtig was wir auch in
schleswig-holstein mittragen wobei ich
ausdrücklich sagen will dass es hier um
mindeststandards geht die gesetzt werden
und das natürlich länder mit höheren
instanzen auch noch weitere
einschränkungen auch durchführen können
ich will mich darauf konzentrieren was
diese verabredung von heute für uns in
schleswig-holstein bedeuten hier
unterstützen natürlich sehr dass das im
tempo erhöht wird erst impfung
zweitimpfung booster impfung seit heute
gelten auch an beginnt gibt es auch
anmeldemöglichkeiten für alle
bürgerinnen und bürger an den
impfstellen entsprechend das heißt nicht
nur die über 60-jährigen das ist frei
geschaltet funktioniert bei uns in
schleswig holstein seit heute auch wir
haben ja bereits bekannt gegeben dass ab
sommer amt im einzelhandel 2 gilt ich
will sehr deutlich heute hier auch
nochmal sagen dass dieser weg in
schleswig-holstein sicherlich nicht
alleine beschritten worden wäre ich
hatte ihm berichtet dass sich mit dass
wir mit den expertinnen und experten
auch gesprochen haben die diesen schritt
für schleswig holstein nicht als
notwendig angesehen haben aber man muss
immer sehen hamburg hatte diese
entscheidung bereits getroffen 14 andere
länder haben es angekündigt und deswegen
ist ja auch klar dass ein land wie
schleswig holstein in einer solchen
situation dann nicht sagen kann wir
machen als einziges land nicht zweig
weil dann natürlich die situation auch
so gewesen wäre gerade im umland von
hamburg richtung mecklenburg vorpommern
dass wir hier quasi auch
einkaufsmöglichkeiten für ungeimpfte
geschaffen hätten und ich glaube dass
der einzelhandel dann der erste gewesen
wäre der gesagt hätte bitte einheitliche
regeln auch in ganz deutschland ich will
auch sehr deutlich sagen dass wir eine
sehr hohe impfquoten in schleswig
holstein haben ich habe heute gesehen
dass umsatzausfälle dort befürchtet
werden wir noch mal darauf verweisen
dass nach den regeln die wir haben nur
300 80.000 menschen davon betroffen sind
das heißt über 2,5 millionen menschen in
schleswig holstein können weiterhin im
einzelhandel einkaufen das sind 87
prozent die übrigens durch diese
regelung auch noch sicherer einkaufen
können und ich glaube dass es insgesamt
auch für den einzelhandel eine gute
nachricht wir haben uns heute darauf
verständigt wie das kontroll wiesen dort
sein soll gesprächen über
stichprobenkontrollen durchgeführt
werden ich glaube das ist überall auch
handball handball und das können die
läden auch umsetzen das heißt es ist
jeder händler verpflichtet einen
deutlichen ausgang zu machen das zutritt
nur für 2022 g zulässig ist und bei
verstößen gegen diese zweig regelung ist
nicht der jeweilige händler mit dem
bußgeld zu belegen sondern die einst der
einzelne ungeimpfte kunde der sich dort
auch im laden auffällt aber das soll
stichprobenartig kontrolliert werden und
das wird gegebenenfalls auch durch
ordnungsämter und noch gegebenenfalls
durch die polizei auch mit unterstützt
werden wir haben die ausnahmen von der
zweig regel entsprechend definiert das
gilt für lebens und futtermittel
angebote für wochenmärkte getränkemärkte
apotheken geschäfte für medizinische
hilfsmittel und produkte drogerien
tankstellen poststellen reformhäuser
baby fachmärkte zeitungsverkauf
buchhandlung bau und gartenmärkte
blumengeschäfte hier bedarf es märkte
sowie lebensmittel ausgabestellen der
tafel glaube das ist ein gutes regelwerk
was dann entsprechend auch umgesetzt
werden kann die weiteren beschlüsse die
wir heute verabredet haben werden bei
uns in schleswig-holstein natürlich auch
umgesetzt das gilt dann für die zeit der
nächsten verordnungs runde ab dem 15
dezember und diese verordnung wird dann
bis zum 11 januar gelten ich glaube es
eine gute rechtssicherheit die wir dann
auch den bürgerinnen bürgern in
schleswig holstein geben können habe
dann gelten auch die einschränkung für
private zusammenkünfte ich hatte das
bereits angekündigt aber da haben wir
uns darauf verständigt die geht es
insbesondere darum wenn ungeimpfte daran
beteiligt sind das jetzt eine regelung
gilt hausstand plus maximal zwei
personen wobei davon ausdrücklich bis
14-jährige personen auch ausgenommen
sein werden wir haben uns auch darauf
verständigt für
großveranstaltungen mit überregionalen
charakter eine teilnehmerbegrenzung von
50 prozent einzuführen das werden wir in
schleswig holstein auch ausschöpfen das
gilt beispielsweise auch für stadien für
hallen besucher das heißt bei holstein
kiel werden ab diesem zeitpunkt dann
auch die hälfte der kapazität also etwa
7 halt bis 8000 zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer beim thw sind es 5000 ich
glaube in flensburg handewitt etwas über
3.000 die dann noch in die halle dort
rein dürfen wir dann hier günther war
das in kiel ministerpräsident schleswig
holstein bleiben im norden ich hatte
ihnen versprochen mecklenburg vorpommern
manuela schwesig die ministerpräsidentin
und die hat jetzt das wort entsperren
jetzt eher starten aber mir war es
wichtig nach der video schalte mit der
bundeskanzlerin im zukünftigen
bundeskanzler und meinen kolleginnen und
kollegen zunächst auch die akteure in
mecklenburg vorpommern zu informieren
die landesregierung die fraktion im
landtag die landräte und
oberbürgermeister und natürlich auch
vertreter der unternehmen und verbände
und gewerkschaften das ist deshalb
wichtig weil uns sehr am herzen liegt
beschlüsse dann auch in der praxis gut
umzusetzen
das war heute eine gute
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz mit frau
merkel und herrn scholz und klar ist wir
werden bundesweit die empfehlungen der
leopoldina im großen und ganzen umsetzen
und die benötigen beschlüsse bestätigen
den kurs in mecklenburg vorpommern denn
dort setzen wir bereits auf zweig plus
auf kontakt beschränkungen wir haben
clubs und diskotheken geschlossen und es
ist richtig dass viele dieser maßnahmen
jetzt auch deutschlandweit kommen wir
sehen an der vierten welle das uns
eigentlich nur eines hilft in
deutschland um aus der pandemie
endgültig raus zu und das ist ein
vollständiger impfschutz der bevölkerung
und dazu muss jetzt noch mehr geimpft
werden und vor allem gemustert werden
und solange wir nicht die vierte welle
durch das boostern und impfen brechen
brauchen wir parallel einschränkungen
und wir haben uns ganz klar auf
einschränkungen für ungeimpfte
verständigt und es gilt jetzt in
deutschland zweig und in vielen
bundesländern zweig plus wie in
mecklenburg vorpommern und das bedeutet
und kontakt beschränkung für ungeimpfte
und das bedeutet faktisch ein lockdown
für ungeimpfte und das ist auch
gerechtfertigt denn die ungeimpften
machen 90 prozent das
infektionsgeschehen aus und wir können
es nicht mehr vertreten dass viele dass
sich die mehrzahl in deutschland hat
impfen lassen doppelt sich jetzt
boosters und gleichzeitig erlebt weil
andere sich nicht impfen lassen wird
wieder unser gesundheitssystem
überlastet gibt es wieder
einschränkungen stehen wieder stehen wir
wieder vor großen problemen und viele
die sich geschützt haben müssen jetzt
dennoch ihre knie oder hüfte op absagen
weil andere wegen co wird behandelt
werden müssen und deshalb ist es auch
richtig dass der deutsche bundestag über
eine impfpflicht diskutiert beraten und
entscheiden wird bis dahin brauchen wir
einschränkungen und die treffen vor
allem die ungeimpften das heißt
ungeimpfte können zukünftig nicht mehr
einfach shoppen gehen ins restaurant
gehen aber auch geimpfte müssen sich
zusätzlich testen lassen und wichtig
sind die kontakt beschränkung dass
zukünftig ungeimpfte nur noch allein im
haushalt bleiben können und maximal ein
oder zwei personen dazu kommen dafür
wird das bundesgesetz geändert ich
erhoffe mir sehr dass wir mit impfen und
postern und gleichzeitig auch den
einschränkungen für ungeimpfte vor allem
die vierte welle brechen können klar ist
wenn wir beim impfen und postern zulegen
sollen dann brauchen wir auch genügend
impfstoff und die video schalte die ich
eben hatte mit unserem hausärzteverband
und auch mit dem verband der
allgemeinmediziner
und der niedergelassenen ärzte die bei
uns vor allem in der fläche impfen hat
mir wieder bestätigt dass zu wenig
impfstoff vor ort ankommt wenn die ärzte
nur 30 dosen bekommen anstatt 100 wie
sie bestellt haben können sie eben nur
30 impfung machen und nicht 100 und
deswegen wäre es dringend notwendig dass
der neue krisenstab unter leitung von
general breuer diese im flug ist geklärt
es nutzt nichts wenn immer wieder
behauptet wird es ist genug impfstoff da
der impfstoff muss in unseren arztpraxen
ankommen dort wird geimpft dort wird
gepostet und der impfstoff muss
natürlich auch in den impfzentren
ankommen
wie geht es weiter in mecklenburg
vorpommern wir haben bereits in einer
cola verordnung die eine die große
mehrzahl dieser
dieser konkreten maßnahmen die wir heute
beschlossen haben schon verankert sie
gelten bereits wir werden morgen im
landtag eine debatte haben und der
landtag wird noch mal beschlüsse fassen
wie wir weitermachen in mecklenburg
vorpommern und dann wird die verordnung
nächste woche noch einmal entsprechend
angepasst sobald die bundesverordnung
zur kontakt beschränkung verändert ist
während die kontakt beschränkungen in
mecklenburg vorpommern mecklenburg
vorpommern noch mal nachgeschärft jetzt
gilt fünf personen aus maximal zwei
haushalten und zukünftig kann es nur
noch ein haushalt sein und zwei personen
dürfen dazu kommen
ministerpräsidentin wo waren denn auch
hier das nicht bei den beratungen jetzt
in verbindung
die großen größten hören waren in der
debatte um großveranstaltungen um
sportveranstaltungen es gibt einige
länder die weiterhin
sportveranstaltungen mit einer großzahl
von zuschauern zu lassen wollen hier hat
man sich darauf verständigt dass egal
wie die instanz ist großveranstaltungen
nur noch 30 bis 50 prozent der kapazität
bis maximal 15.000 personen sein können
ich halte das wie viele meiner kollegen
für viel zu viel und deshalb ist es
richtig dass die länder die ein hohes
infektionsgeschehen haben hier weitaus
tiefer die zuschauerzahl begrenzen
können und für mecklenburg vorpommern
gilt bereits beim fußball 1000 zuschauer
zweig plus und mehr ist nicht möglich so
ein beschluss hätten sich viele
gewünscht aber das ist jetzt auch ein
guter kompromiss wenn es bundesländer
gibt wie nrw oder hessen die sagen wir
machen noch mehr zuschauer dann müssen
sie das verantworten
wir können uns vor ort nicht mehr
verantworten solange die pflegekräfte
und intensiv ärztinnen ärzte um das
leben der menschen auf den
intensivstationen kämpfen man muss sich
ja auch mal in der lage versetzen die
kämpfen um die kurve patienten die haben
nicht zeit ständig stundenlangen
sitzungen zu machen sondern sie kämpfen
und sie wollen auch von uns das signal
das wir uns alle einschränken und dass
wir alle den ernst der lage verstanden
haben und dass wir bereit sind zu
verzichten und ich kann auch den frust
von geimpften verstehen die gesagt haben
hallo ich habe alles gemacht warum darf
ich denn jetzt nicht zum fußball warum
muss ich mich testen lassen wenn ich ins
restaurant muss warum soll ich mich
nicht privat mehr meine große
geburtstagsfeier machen diesen frust
verstehe ich aber die lage ist eben sehr
schwierig und wir müssen auch an die
denken die jeden tag das leben anderer
retten und deswegen ist es auch ein
wichtiges signal und gleichzeitig ist
aber der größte einschnitt wirklich bei
den ungeimpften und da waren sich alle
von anfang an einig ungeimpfte können
nur noch sehr eingeschränkt am
gesellschaftlichen leben teilhaben so
lange sie sich nicht impfen lassen
manuela schwesig war dass die
ministerpräsidentin des bundeslandes
mecklenburg vorpommern gerade erst
erfolgreich die landtagswahl ende
september bestritten meine damen und
herren dieser erste teil des tages
verlangt nach einem sagen wir mal
versöhnlichen abschluss der wird heute
abend geliefert ab 19 uhr 20 übrigens
live in unserem programm mit dem
zapfenstreich für die scheidende
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel das war
heute hier ihre letzte
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz sie hat das
sozusagen die bundeswehr ein bisschen
herausgefordert damit mit dem was sie an
musikwünschen
präsentiert hat drei darf man sich
wünschen wenn man diese ehrung